BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION
IS CALLED TO ORDER. AND I HAVE
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS AT
FIRST. AND THOSE ARE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND THE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS WE HAVE
MADE TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
HOLDING THE COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. OF CENTER
MINUTES HERE AND WE ACCEPT
EXPECTS SENATOR- CHAU BOGOTA ON
THE GERMAN OF ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FOR A REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY
HELP IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE. IN THE PROGRAM. PANTAR
IT PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE ONCE YOU ONE MUTANT
SPEAK. AND ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A CASUAL IT
TAKES A FEW SECONDS TO GET THE
RIGHT PERSON ON THE SCREEN. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS. WE HAVE
ALLOWED FOR ADMITTING MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
THIS ONE. IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
AND FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE CO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE WILL HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE CLOSE OF THE PRESENTATION
OF THE DIFFERENT ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA SO WE'LL DO IT ALL AT
ONCE AFTER THE THIRTEEN ITEMS
HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE OR- HAVE POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE'S. WEBSITE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN BUT ALL
ANNOUNCES NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE
SIX SEVEN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
EXCUSE ME. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE
FOUR EIGHT NINE SEVEN. SIX FIVE
FOUR. EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE- TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE- ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. THAN
ANY INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
OF OUR WALL WHEN WE GET TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. LIMIT EACH ONE
TO ONE MINUTE SO PLEASE DONT.
MAKE SURE THAT ARE YOU ARE
PREPARED TO DO ONE MINUTE AND
IF IT GOES A LITTLE OVER I WILL
UNFORTUNATELY CUT YOU OFF- THIS
IS THE SEVENTH OUT OF EIGHT
HEARINGS OF OUR REGULAR SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS TO HEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF SUB
COMMITTEE ONE THESE HEARINGS
ARE LARGELY INFORMATIONAL
DESIGNED FOR DISCUSSION OF THE
ISSUES AND TO TAKE FEEDBACK TO
INFORM ACTIONS WILL BE TAKEN
LATER IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS IN APRIL OR MAY. IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL. REVIEW
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
REGARDING HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BY BERRY ADULT EDUCATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. WE HAVE THIRTEEN
ITEMS TODAY WITH PANELS FOR
EACH ONE SO I'M REALLY GOING TO
ASK PEOPLE TO BE EFFICIENT WITH
THEIR TESTIMONY AND I HATE TO
SAY IT BUT IF SOMEBODY JUST
REALLY FEELS OBLIGATED TO GO ON
A BIT I MIGHT CUT THEM OFF. AND
ARE WE ARE GOING TO COMBINE I
THINK- ISSUES TWO AND THREE
WITH THE STATE LIBRARY AND HAVE
THE PANELISTS PERCENT ON BOTH
FROM ABOUT ONCE SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE THROUGH THAT ONE. SO
SENATOR MEN DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS. OKAY THEN- WE
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW PRESENTING WILL BE
BRIAN RUTLEDGE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DAVID
FIGMENT CHANCELLOR AND DEAN
DAVID STEWARD THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER AND CHASES
AND CONSTANT TOURISTS OF THE
ALEJO'S OFFICE. NO THE OTHERS
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS WILL GO IN THAT ORDER
SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH MR RUTLEDGE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS BRIAN
RUTLEDGE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
A TWO POINT ONE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION THE
COVER HASTINGS OPERATING COSTS.
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT
TUITION REMAINED FLAT. FOR THE
TWO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC YEAR. THE
CONTEXT IS THAT HASTINGS BOARD
OF DIRECTORS VOTED IN THE FALL
TO. INCREASE TUITION FOR
NONRESIDENTS SEVEN PERCENT.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD. BE
PREMISED ON THEM RESTORE
SENDING THAT SO THAT THE
EQUIVALENT NET REVENUE WOULD BE
OUR GO TO HASTINGS. COMPLETE
YOUR PRESENTATION. THAT DOES
THE PROPOSAL IS STATE TWO POINT
ONE ONGOING GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DAVID FIGMENT WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
CHAIRED- GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE- I AM
TRANSCEND BEING GIVEN EGGMAN
SOB JOINED BY A LOT OF MY CFO
DAVID STEWARD. DESPITE THE
GREAT CHALLENGES OF THE
PANDEMIC ARE YOU SEE THESE
THINGS IT IS ARMY CONTINUES TO
ENJOY A STRONG UPWARD
TRAJECTORY. OUR OUR
APPLICATIONS ARE UP OVER 25%
THIS YEAR. ARE WE EXPECTED MADE
A CLASSROOM PROXIMALLY THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY AND THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUT WITH A
VERY STRONG BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE. OUR LEGAL EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM WE ARE I
WHICH TURNED FIFTY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CONTINUES ITS STRONG
APPLICATIONS- AND IT REPRESENTS
20% OF OUR INCOMING CLASS. ARE
WE WILL HAVE A OUR THIRD COHORT-
CALIFORNIA SCHOLARS THIS COMING
YEAR AND OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOLARS AS THE COMMITTEE
LIKELY. OUR HOW WHEN YOU'RE
READY WHO ARE GRAD OF THE H. C.
U. ARE THEY READ- SCHOLAR. AND
A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR EURO STYLE
AND ARE THE COVER ROOM AD
BOARD. OF OUR NEW ACADEMIC.
OPENED ON MARCH TWENTY ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY. WAS
CLOSE THE SAME DAY BECAUSE OF
KOBE. NINETEEN AND IT IS THAT
YOU DON'T GIRL THE THAT AWAIT
ARE RETURN CAMPUS- AND IS IT
WERE RECALL- THE WERE EIGHT BY
A NOW. BUT GOOD GALA. IN THE
NOT THIS FIVE DOLLAR. ARE WE
BEGAN CAN- WE DON'T AND EMOTION
OR ALL THAT BILL AT ONE NINETY
EIGHT. SIX BURKE TWENTY TWENTY.
I ANY IS DOES TO BE. IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY. IT WILL BE A
FOURTEEN STORY. WHERE STORIES
REPLACEMENT SPECIALISTS- AND
STORE ARE SUBSIDIZED HOW. BUT
WE WILL BE STRONGER THE
UNIVERSE HEALTH. AND IT YOU
KNOW HELPFUL HAPPEN. MEDICAL
GRANT FARM- AND NURSING-
PARTNERSHIPS WITH YOU SEE. TO
ANSWER IF YOU CAMPUS SINCE THE
ARKANSAS TO GROW. I WE ALREADY
HAVE A ROBUST- PARTNERSHIPS
THIS YES SOUTH. AND EAST DAVIS
SCHOOL MAN. ALL OF THEM OF
COURSE AS YOU. LIKELY KNOW OUR
A NINE. WAS SELECTED TO BE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
ARE WE WILL HAVE A BALANCED
BUDGET OUR NEXT YEAR. AND WE
FULLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HOW WE HAVE RESCINDED
THE TUITION INCREASE. AND WE
THANK OF THE GOVERNOR WE THANK
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. FOR
ITS. CONTINUING SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WAS VERY TO. VIEW TO. THE
PRESIDENT DOWN WITH ABOUT BUT
IN YOUR LIST OF THINGS- MISTER
STEWART DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS I KNOW THIS
FROM COMMON. THANK YOU AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE THE OHIO. HI JASON
CONCENTRA CELILO I'M IN MY
TESTIMONY I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON
THREE THINGS THE FIRST IS TO
TALK ABOUT BY HASTINGS OVERALL
ON FINDING AND FUNDING BY
SOURCE THE SECOND I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT IS HASTINGS UP PLANS
TO SPEND THE IT'S SIMON
DISSIPATING FUNDING INCREASES
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. AND THEN
THE THIRD IS TO PROVIDE OUR
THOUGHTS ON THESE MATTERS SO
STARTING ON THE FIRST ISSUE- I
WOULD DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION. TO
PAGE TWO OF YOUR AGENDA- WHICH
HAS WHY AND FIGURE ONE- SHE
HE'S- ON COURT BY. AND THE KEY
AWAYS WITH FIGURE IS THAT HE
INTO A FOR INCREASE OF SIXTY A
HALF NOW. IN THE BY YEAR. IN
ADDITION TO THE JOHN FUND ON.
DESCRIBED BY THE MINISTRY. HE
SINGS IS ALL- ANTICIPATE. OUR
REVENUE GROWTH IN TUITION FEAR
OF. AS IT MISSED ARE NO. UNDER
THIS FOR HAS TO WERE NOT
INCREASED CHOI FIRST AND- THIS
REVENUE GROW IS JOE. FOR BY AND
WILL GROWTH ARE YOU CAN SEE IN
THE TO. HE STINGS. A NINE AND A
HALF PERCENT INCREASE THE
MOMENT IN THE BUDGET. AFTER THE
SECOND ISSUE HOW WOULD HE SING
SPELL THIS ONE. IN I WOULD
DIRECTOR TO PAY. THREE YOUR
AGENDA THAT LAST. WHICH PROVIDE.
A NARRATIVE SOME OF HOW SINGS
WITH ITS ON- THE KEY TAKE AWAY.
IS THAT TWO POINT NINE. OF THIS
CARE. WOULD GO TO SUPPORT A
BASIC WORKLOAD BUDGET.
CONSISTING OF THINGS LIKE
EMPLOYEE SALARY INCREASES WOULD
COVER OPERATING COSTS SUCH AS
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT COSTS. AND
THEN THE REMAINING THREE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO THE SCHOOL TO
ADDRESS ITS BUDGET DEFICIT. AND
ON THIS LATTER POINT- THERE'S
SOME GOOD NEWS HERE- HE STANDS
IN SUCH A PAGE TO ELIMINATE ITS
DEFICIT. I THAT HAD EXIST PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. I'M IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND ACTUALLY
ANTICIPATES ENDING THE BUDGET
YOU'RE WITH A BUDGET SURPLUS.
WE THINK THIS IS A POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT- THIS YEAR'S. WELL
IN TERMS OF OUR THOUGHTS ON
THESE MATTERS- WE THINK LOOKING
AT TASTING SPENDING PLAN- SIX
SUGGESTS THAT THE PROPOSAL
LEVEL OF FUNDING IS ADEQUATE TO
SUPPORT HE SINGS BUDGET WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
EVEN TREAT THIS AUGMENTATION AS
A MAXIMUM LEVEL SUPPORT AND HOW
SOME OPTIONS TO ADJUST
ACCORDINGLY WHERE- THE KNEE
REVISION TO COME AND- WITH THE-
WORST BUDGET CONDITION AND WE
HAVE CURRENTLY I'M FOR EXAMPLE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONTEMPLATE
SUPPORTING DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EMPLOYEE SALARIES COULD ALSO
CONCENTRATE ON A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF BUDGET SURPLUS FOR THE
SCHOOL. AGAIN THESE ARE ALL
THINGS LEGISLATURE COULD WEIGH
ONCE IT HAS MORE INFORMATION
THAN THEY- ARE MADE ANALYSIS
ARE ARE ARE ANALYSIS- THAT WE
SUBMITTED- PUBLICLY A FEW DAYS
AGO- HAD A FEW OTHER SECTIONS
IN IT WE HAD A SECTION TALKING
ABOUT- STUDENT TUITION LEVELS
ARE GETTING SOME TRADE OFFS TO
THINK ABOUT WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT TUITION
INCREASES AT THESE THINGS WE
ALSO HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
ACQUIRE HASTINGS TO REPORT ON
HIS EXPERIENCE ON USING ONLINE
EDUCATION DURING THE PANDEMIC.
BOB FOR THE SAKE OF TIME ALL
LEAVE- FURTHER ELABORATION
ABOUT. SECURITY IS NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND OF I
WOULD JUST STATE DID. NORMALLY
I MIGHT HAVE A QUESTION OR TWO
TO DRAW THIS OUT WE HAVE.
THIRTEEN ISSUES AND I KNOW
SENATOR MAN HAS A QUESTION SO
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THE
PRESENTATION SAID THE AGENDA.
CLEARLY ELUCIDATED THIS AND
WE'LL SEE WHERE WE ARE AT THE
TIME OF THE MAY REVISE AND
VISITORS TO CENTER GOVERNMENT.
YEAH I JUST HAD A I GUESS I
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND IT IT
SEEMS TO ME IF I'M STATING THIS
CORRECTLY. AND THAT WE ARE BACK
FILLING THE 10% CUT FROM LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. AND THEN
PROVIDING A LITTLE BIT OF AN
INCREASE THIS YEAR. I IN RETURN
UC HASTINGS WILL HOLD ITS
TUITION FLAT THIS YEAR. AND I'M
A BIG FAN OF YOU SEE ACING
SCHOOL LIVE FRIENDS THERE- I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS- WHY IS UC
HASTINGS BEING TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM OTHER LAW
SCHOOLS IN THE SYSTEM. AS WELL
AS OTHER. DEPARTMENTS AND
UNIVERSITIES. ARE THERE PLANS
TO TRY TO. BACK FILL ANY OF THE
OTHER UC'S OR THE UC HASTINGS
GOING TO BE A ONE OFF AND THIS
QUESTION WILL BE DIRECTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FOR
THE APARTMENT OF FINANCE. BRIAN
RELIGIOUS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I THINK THE QUESTION SENATOR I
WOULD KNOW THAT HASTINGS THE
PROPOSAL IS FOR A SPECIFIC
TUITION INCREASE THAT THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS PROPOSED IN THE
FALL. AND IT'S A TWO POINT ONE
NET REVENUE GAIN THAT THAT
TUITION INCREASE WOULD HAVE
EARNED IN RESOURCES FOR
HASTINGS CHART PROPOSAL IS TO
PROVIDE THE TWO POINT ONE
SPECIFICALLY TO BALANCE OUT
THAT TUITION AND TO FUNCTION AS
A TUITION BY OUR- IN TERMS OF-
TREATING. DIFFERENTLY THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T THAT'S
NOT THE APPROACH. AS WE VIEW IT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE BUDGET IT IN A IN A VERY
SPECIFIC WAY WHERE IT'S SO MUCH
LARGER AND FUNCTIONS AND IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS INCLUDING
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION WHICH
IS THE LARGEST COMPONENT OF
STATE FUNDING- YEAH. BUT IT
JUST THIS IS THE APPROACH THAT
WE'VE TAKEN FOR HASTINGS ON
WHAT THE UC WE HAVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
THEN LAST WEEK IT WAS ANNOUNCED
THAT. WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. ON
TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SURVEY AND I UNDERSTAND
OBVIOUSLY HASTINGS'S IS A
SPECIAL CASE BUT- WHEN YOU TALK
TO ANYBODY IN UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM I THINK THERE
IS A CONCERN THERE THAT THEY
ARE. BEING ASKED TO DO A LOT
RIGHT NOW ALSO BEING ASKED TO
HOLD TUITIONS FLAT. AND SO- IS
THIS THAT STRIKE ME AS A SAID
IN ICE ICE AND FULLY SUPPORT
THE THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
FOR HASTINGS I GUESS I. WHAT
I'M WONDERING IS WHY THE REST
THE UC'S HAVE BEEN SINGLED OUT.
WITH I THINK IT LEASES THE LAST
HEARING WE HAD A THREE PERCENT.
INCREASE WHICH COMES ON THE 10%
CUT LAST YEAR SO- I GUESS I I'M
HEARING FROM YOU THERE'S NO
PLANS TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
OR PROVIDE ANYTHING LIKE THIS
LEVEL OF- AUGMENTATION FOR THE
UC SYSTEM. WELL I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT WE ARE PROPOSING
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
BUT LAST WEEK WE- ARE PROPOSAL
NOW IS TO HAVE. ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THE UC SYSTEM
AS A WHOLE. AND SO. WE CAN
ELABORATE MORE- UPSET THE UC
RANG- BUT I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES BOTH IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL AND LAST WEEK
DO ACCOUNT FOR. THE RESOURCE
NEEDS OF THE UC SYSTEM. THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU- SENATOR MEN
AND JUST TO NOTE THAT THE- OUR
EIGHTH AND FINAL HEARING MONDAY
MORNING WILL BE ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO
THERE WILL BE A CHANCE IF THERE
IS A REASON TO VOTE TO RAISE
THAT ISSUE THAT. LET ME THANK-
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE HERE
FOR THE FIRST PANEL WE
APPRECIATE IT WHO ARE WE WILL
PROBABLY SEE YOU AGAIN IN APRIL
AND MAY AND WE WILL MOVE TO
ITEMS TWO AND THREE THEY'RE
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY. THE ISSUE TO IS TO SIT
BOX AND LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
ISSUE THREE IS THE EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS. AND WHILE
THE EIGHT CORE TWO SEPARATE
ITEMS IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT WE HAD
THE SAME THREE PANELISTS FOR
BOTH TWO ITEMS WILL HAVE THEM
PERCENT THOSE ITEMS TOGETHER
AND THEN TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AND
THE PANEL WILL BE JENNIFER
LOUIS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. A GREG LUCAS TO STATE
LIBRARIAN AND AGAIN JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
KOLEOS OFFICE WILL BEGIN WITH
JENNIFER WILL BE WELCOME TO
THE- TO THE COMMITTEE. I THINK
YOU'RE MUTED SOMETIMES. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS JENNIFER
LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE STATE LIBRARY
AUGMENTATIONS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OUR CONTINUATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EMPHASIS ON
EQUITY ACCESS AND BUDGET
RESILIENCY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TWO POINT THREE
MILLION ONGOING JOURNAL FINE
AND EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR TOTAL
AUGMENTATION FOR THE STATE
LIBRARY AT TEN POINT THREE
MILLION. STATE LIBRARY ONGOING
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE THE
CONTINUATION OF THE ONLINE
SERVICE SYSTEMS OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS THE ZIP BOOK PROGRAM AND
LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY THE BUS IT
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES ONE TIME
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL LIBRARY
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND BOOK
MOBILES AND EARLY LEARNING AND
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WITH THE
ACTUAL CONCLUDE MY WITH MY
PRESENTATION I'D BE HAPPY TO GO
INTO FURTHER DETAIL AS
REQUESTED AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN
WILL WELCOME THE STATE
LIBRARIAN GREG LUCAS WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. FORENING THANK
YOU- I DON'T I DON'T DON'T
INTEREST THE COMMITTEES TIME I
DON'T REALLY HAVE MUCH TO ADD
SO WHAT JENNIFER SAID. THERE IS.
I MEAN IT'S TERRIFIC THAT LUNCH
AT THE LIBRARY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS NOW AN
ON GOING COME. APPROPRIATION
WHICH HELPS HELPS IN PLANNING
WHICH HELPS POTENTIALLY EXPAND
THE PROGRAM AND DO A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS- BUT BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE PROGRAM WORD
STEEDS KIDS IN. SUMMER TIME-
THE IF THE MONEY CAN SHOW UP AT
THE LIBRARY SOMETIME THIS
SPRING RATHER THAN JULY ONE
WHEN THE BUDGET TAKES EFFECT.
THEN IT CAN BE PUT TO GOOD USE
AND FEEDING HUNGRY FOR KIDS
THIS SUMMER. AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT I KNOW IS HAS SAID
TO US THAT THEY- IT IS YOU
DON'T WANT TO WORK TO SEE IF WE
CAN FIND A VEHICLE TO MAKE. THE
DELIVERY OF THOSE FUNDS HAPPEN
AND THEY'VE BEEN CONVERSATIONS
WITH FOLKS FROM THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND B.
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
I. I JUST WANT TO SAY THANKS
FOR EVERYONE'S WILLINGNESS TO
TRY AND SEE IF WE CAN- COME IN
UP FRONT. TO MAKE MAKE THAT
WORK. AND A AGAIN LIKE ALL ARE
EITHER ARE. YOU KNOW THE STAFF
RECOMMENDS HOLDING THEM OPEN SO
IF THERE'S QUESTIONS GREAT BUT
OTHERWISE WE CAN JUST ALL THE
ITEMS OPEN. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE L. A. ALL RIGHT SO- AS THIS
IS A COMBINED ISSUE TO ISSUE
THREE I'LL TALK ABOUT BOTH
ISSUES IN MY TESTIMONY- FOR
ISSUE TO- WHICH WOULD BE- THE
ONGOING PROPOSALS. ON WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF- CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL MY PRIMARY CONCERN IS
JUST AROUND THE STATE'S- BUDGET
CONDITION- AND PRECARIOUS
BUDGET CONDITION AND PROJECTED
OUT YOUR DATA SETS. THIS ISN'T
UP THE MOST OPPORTUNE TIME TO
BE- OUR FUNDING WHAT WHAT ARE
EFFECTIVE WHAT EFFECTIVELY BEEN
PILOTS ON ON GOING BASIS. IN
ADDITION TO THAT- WE RAISE SOME
CONCERNS IN THE PAST WITH SOME
OF THESE INITIATIVES- THAT WE
THAT WE THINK MERIT- EITHER
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL OR
POTENTIALLY MODIFYING- SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS. AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'D BE HAPPY
TO OPERATE MORE ON JUNE EIGHTH
THAT'S OF INTEREST TO THE
COMMITTEE- BUT GIVEN THESE
FACTORS ARE ON ISSUE TOO ANYWAY
WE RECOMMENDED THAT. YOU HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN YOU GET MORE
INFORMATION IT NAY REDUCTION-
ASSESS THE STATE'S BUDGET
SITUATION. THE BUDGET SITUATION
WERE TO WORSEN AND YOU ARE
FACING- MANY OTHER ONGOING
PARTY START THE BUDGET. THESE
COULD BE THE KINDS OF PROPOSALS
THAT YOU COULD CONSIDER TOWARDS
OUR REDIRECTION FOR THOSE
HIGHER PRIORITIES. NO ONE ISSUE.
THREE WHICH ARE ONE TIME
PROPOSALS. WE HAD A DIFFERENT.
FOR THAT PROPOSED EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL FIVE MILLION
OF THAT IS FOR- AFTER SCHOOL
AND EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS AT
LIBRARIES. AND THE THREE
MILLION IS FOR- WHAT WE CALL
BOOK MOBILE PROGRAM SAID THINGS.
LIKE OUR PURCHASING VEHICLE
THAT CAN YOU TO THE RE TO BE
TRENDS ALWAYS THE LIKE FOR AND
OTHER REALLY ACT THAT X.
SERVICE TO LIVE- INTO THE
COMMUNITY. ARE SYSTEM FIVE NO
IS- OTHER ALREADY PROVIDES THE
AND TO LOCAL I. T. AGENCIES. ON
TO PROVIDE FREE AND CATER TO
AND SO THE REAL FROM US SET OF
FOR Y. TO THE START HE STARTS
BACK. I DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE A
CLEAR RASH TO A WE RECOMMEND
THE FROM OF THE- WHICH- BUT ON
THE PROPOSED THREE DOLLARS WE
THINK THAT COULD MERIT MORE
CONSIDERATION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE- IT DOES SEEM MORE
NARROWLY TAILORED TOWARDS- VERY
SPECIFIC LIBRARY SERVICES AND
ALSO IT IT DOES SEEM TO HAVE
SOME CONNECTION TO THE PANDEMIC
OR OR COULD TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT. HELPS GET A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY ACCESS ALL LIBRARIES
AND THEN IT RESOURCES IN THE
MIDST THE PANDEMIC SHOULD NOT
PARTICULARLY FOR THE THREE
MILLION WE THINK IT DOES MERIT
SOME ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION-
AND YOU COULD WEIGH THAT
AGAINST MANY OF THE OTHER ONE
TIME PRIORITIES WHEN IT COMES
TIME TO MAKING FINAL. BUDGET
SECONDS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ABOUT TWO EACH OF THE
PANELISTS AND LET ME JUST MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT. WHICH IS OF.
IT YOU KNOW IF WE WEREN'T
PRESSED FOR TIME I MIGHT
ACTUALLY ASKED THE STATE
LIBRARIAN TO EXPAND A LITTLE ON
THE STATE OF THE LIBRARY AND-
AND LONG TERM NEEDS AND LONG
TERM GOVERNMENTS AND SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT. I'M CONFIDENT
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
HIM ON. AND ADDITIONALLY. I
PERSONALLY AM SYMPATHETIC TO
THE NOTION IF WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD WITH THE LAUNCHES OF THE
LIBRARY TO TRIED TO DO IT IN
TIME FOR MAXIMUM IMPACT AND I
HOPE THAT. THAT THERE IS.
THOUGH THAT DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOW TO HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT.
IN A TIMELY FASHION. AND I AM
SURE. AS THE L. A. O. SAID. THE
TRACTORS THAT CHANGE BETWEEN
NOW AND THE MAY REVISE FORMERLY
COVERED SOME OF THESE THINGS
BUT THE EARLY INDICATIONS OURS.
IS ARE WE WILL BE IN GOOD SHAPE
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR AND
THEREFORE THESE THINGS WILL. BE
STRONGLY CONSIDERED. THE SO
WITH THAT I JUST THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU BEING HERE TODAY. AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FISH YOU
NUMBER FOUR. WHICH IS ANOTHER
ISSUE OF THE STATE LIBRARY IT'S
THE CORPORATION FOR EDUCATION
NETWORK INITIATIVES OR SCENIC.
AND THE PANELISTS WILL BE THREE
OF THE- ARE. THE THREE PREVIOUS
PENELAS WAS TO MORE FROM.
SCENIC AND- I DON'T KNOW IF
BOTH ARE SPEAKING FROM SCENIC
BUT OF THE PANELISTS ARE
JENNIFER. LOUIS GREG LUCAS
GROWL READING CROWN. TONY
MILLION AND JASON CONSTANT.
WILL GO IN THAT ORDER WILL
BEGIN ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WITH
JENNIFER. LOUIS HELLO AGAIN AS
JENNIFER WE WOULD DEPART OF
FINE. THE GOVERNOR'S BY AND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND GENERAL
FINE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ON A FINE
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND ON A PLANE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
ONGOING FOR THE CORPORATION FOR
SCENIC NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO KNOWN AS
SCENIC. THESE FUNDS WILL PAY
FOR INCREASED CYBERSECURITY AND
OPERATIONAL COSTS RELATING TO
CONTINUE PUBLIC LIBRARY
PARTICIPATION AND SCENIC. THESE
FUNDS WILL SUPPORT REAL TIME
ONGOING MONITORING AND
MANAGEMENT OF ALL LIBRARY
CONNECTIONS ON THE NETWORK
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SECURITY INFORMATION AND EVENT
MANAGEMENT TOOLS. AND ENHANCED
NETWORK PERFORMANCE AND COVER
ANNUAL INCREASE IN THE COST OF
RUNNING THE NETWORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THAT WILL
CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION I AM
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND MOVED TO THE MISTER LUCAS
THE STATE LIBRARY. NO I CAN'T
IMPROVE ON JENNIFER'S RIVETING
PRESENTATION. BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ASK ANSWER QUESTIONS I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT I MEAN. SOME
QUICK FEES COST INCREASES THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT SCENIC
HAS YOU KNOW HAD ANY INCREASE
FOR ITS MEMBERSHIP WHICH
INCLUDES YOU SEE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. K. THROUGH TWELVE- I
THINK I SAID CSU BUT I MEAN
THEY'VE BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS TO BE SERVED
THEIR FIRST INCREASES IN THE
STATE LIBRARY. ON BEHALF OF
LIBRARIES AROUND CALIFORNIA HAS
MEMBERSHIP ON THE BOARD THE
GOVERNOR THAT HELPS GOVERN
SCENIC. AND SO THESE INCREASES
ARE NECESSARY OR SCENIC
SUSTAINABILITY. AND THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE STATE TO
COVER A PORTION OF THOSE ADDED
COSTS. HELP REDUCE BARRIERS FOR
IN A LESSER RESOURCE LIBRARIES
AROUND THE STATE WHO ARE
PROBABLY THE ONES THAT COULD
USE YOU KNOW IMPROVED HIGH
SPEED CONNECTIVITY MORE THAN
SOME OTHER PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA. ELECTED COULD NOT
STAND THOSE BARRIERS AND ALLOWS
THEM TO PARTICIPATE SO THANK.
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU AND I WON'T.
REMAR YOU TO FUTURE TIME YOU
REFER TO THE FINE PRESS AS
RIVETING. THEN WHEN TO ROME
RINKER FROM A SCENIC. GOOD
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM ROLE RINCON VICE
PRESIDENT OF OPERATIONS AT
SCENIC SCENIC OPERATES EACH
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION NETWORK DELIVERING
BROADBAND SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES. PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND LIBRARIES AS DEMONSTRATED
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN BROADBAND
THIS IS BECOMING ESSENTIAL
SERVICE FOR CALIFORNIANS SEEKS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WITH
SUBSTANTIAL REPRESENTATION BY
FIVE PUBLIC SEGMENTS INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
HAS DEVELOPED A FINANCIAL MODEL
SUPPORT SCENIC BACK BAY FIND
FAIR AND EQUITABLE FOR ALL
MEMBERS. AS MISTER LUCAS WAS
KIND ENOUGH TO POINT OUT OUR
FEES HAVE NOT BEEN RAISED IN
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
INCREASES HAD BECOME NECESSARY
TO ENSURE ADEQUATE FUNDING IN
FUTURE YEARS TO SUSTAIN A HIGH
QUALITY OF SERVICE THAT
DISTINGUISHES SCENIC. GIVEN THE
PRESUMPTION OF RISING COSTS AS
WELL AS TO EXPAND AND SUPPORT
NEW SERVICES IN AREAS VITALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR MEMBERS SUCH
AS CYBERSECURITY AND EVER
EXPANDING BANDWIDTH NEEDS. THE
SCENIC OF DIRECTORS NOT THESE
FEES AS THE BACK NAKED FOR
DISTRIBUTING. FAIRLY AMONG
MEMBERS. THEY WERE CRITICALLY%
AWARE. OF THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS
NEED TO REQUEST FUNDS TO STATE
BUDGET PROCESS SO THE BOARD
INCORPORATED A PHASED APPROACH
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION. IN
KEEPING WITH THE CHAIRS REQUEST
FOR BREVITY WE WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH THE STAFF REGARDING THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AS
REQUESTED BEING IN THE AGENDA.
I WILL DO MY BEST TO ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
TODAY REGARDING THE NEW FEES OR
THE NETWORK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- IT DOES TONY MILLION
WHICH TO SPEAK OR IS HE JUST
HERE FOR QUESTIONS. EASIER FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU RIGHT THEN
WILL MOVE TO THE AUDIO. WE HAVE
TWO MESSAGES ONE ON THE SCENIC
FEE INCREASES WHICH AS WAS
NOTED BY PREVIOUS PANELISTS NOT
ONLY IMPACTS STATE LIBRARY BUT
ALL THE EDUCATION SEGMENTS.
UNINSPECTED SEPARATELY WE HAVE
A MESSAGES ON- THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS PERTAINING TO THE
STATE LIBRARY SPECIFICALLY
SOMEONE AT. ADDRESS EACH ONE OF
THOSE. SO WITH REGARD TO THAT
SCENE ACTUALLY INCREASES. ARE
SEEN IT DID MEET WITH OUR
OFFICE. AND PROVIDED US ON SOME
INFORMATION- FOR EXAMPLE THEY
WALKED US THROUGH- WHAT THE FEE
INCREASES WERE INTENDED TO
COVER- THEY ALSO PROVIDED US A
NARRATIVE SUMMARY OF SOME OF
THE COST PRESSURES AND- EVEN
COUNTERED IN RECENT YEARS. BUT
SCENIC- READ BY DECLINED OUR
REQUEST TO PROVIDE- BASIC
BUDGET INFORMATION- UP ABOUT
ITS ORGANIZATION- FOR EXAMPLE
IT'S FUNDING LEVELS AND FUNDING
BY SOURCE SPENDING LEVELS. THE
SIZE OF ITS SURPLUSES OR
DEFICITS AND THE SIZE OF ITS
ARE RESERVED. WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION WE AREN'T ABLE TO
ASSESS. THE MERITS OF THE FEE
INCREASES. NO I'M TO THE STATE
LIBRARY- ABSENCES OF POLICY
CHANGE THESE ARE COSTS AT THE
STATE LIBRARY WHAT WILL FACE
AND FUNDING THIS PROGRAM SO WE
THINK IT'S REASONABLE THAT THE
STATE- CORPORATION THESE COST
INCREASES INTO ITS BUDGET.
DECISIONS FOR THE PROGRAM- WE
ARE STILL WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE A FEW
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS ABOUT-
SOME OF THE PROPOSED INCREASES
IN WHERE WE'RE STILL FOLLOWING
UP WITH THEM SO WE PLAN TO.
RETURN TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
RETURNS THE CAN BE STAFF AND
PROVIDE THEM. A FULLER
ASSESSMENT ONCE WE GET THOSE
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS RESOLVED
BUT WE DO HAVE ON TWO ISSUES
THAT WE'D LIKE TO RAISE FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS THAT THERE
IS SOME UNSPENT FUNDING- IN
THIS BROADBAND PROGRAM IT'S
CONNECTED TO GRANTS THAT WERE
PROVIDED IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET
THAT WERE INTENDED AS SUCH
LIBRARIES AND- CONNECTING TO
THE INTERNET AND UPGRADING
THEIR INTERNET SPEEDS. AND WE
THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THESE ARMS-
FUNDS COULD BE USED TO OFFSET
SOME OF THESE COSTS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS AND INITIAL YEARS.
WE RECOMMEND YOU GET SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON THE STATE
LIBRARY ON HOW THEY PLAN TO
SPEND THE REMAINING UNSPENT
FUNDS AND SEE IF THEY ARE
POTENTIALLY. AVAILABLE TO
OFFSET SOME OF THESE COSTS. THE
OTHER ISSUE LIKE TO RAISE YOUR
CONCERN. IS RECENT YEARS THERE
HAS BEEN SOME OVER BUDGETING IN
THE PROGRAM- THAT IS. THAT THE
STATE HAS BEEN APPROPRIATING
FUNDS AT A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
LEVELS AND- ACTUAL SPENDING ON
THE PROGRAM SH. AND ACCORDING
TO STATE LIBRARY OF THE PURPOSE
OF THIS IS TO PROVIDE. THE
STATE LIBRARY. A CUSHION IN
CASE THERE IS A UNEXPECTED COST
INCREASES AND NEW YEAR. FOR
EXAMPLE AN EXCHANGE AND
SURCHARGES THAT IT'S CHARGED BY
THE BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. WE OVERREACH IS
ARMING THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS SO INTERNET ITSELF IT'S
NOT IMPACTING THE STATE OUR
GENERAL FUND A CONDITION.
SIGNIFICANT RANGE WE THINK A
MORE RATIONAL APPROACH WOULD BE
TO- APPROPRIATE FINES BASED ON-
PROJECT IT'S PROJECTED COSTS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. AND THEN I
JUST- PROGRAMMATIC SPENDING AS
TIME GOES ON ONCE MORE
INFORMATION COMES AVAILABLE
AND- I JUST STATE LIBRARIES
BUDGET WHERE THEY'RE UNEXPECTED
COST INCREASES. ON THE MERCHANT
TALKING ABOUT IS AN APPROACH WE
TAKE FROM A STATE PROGRAM SO WE
THINK IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE A
REGIONAL APPROACH TAKE CARE TO.
I HAVE A CHANCE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF TWO
QUICK QUESTIONS ARE ONE IS FOR
FINANCE- WHICH IS BASICALLY.
WHAT YOU INTEND TO RECOMMEND
WITH REGARDING TO THE- THE
AMOUNT OF THE UNSPENT FUNDS. AT
GENERALLY WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE ADMINISTRATION'S
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE ONE
POINT THREE MILLION IS CARRY
OVER FOR THE REMAINING FIVE
MILLION A ONE TIME FINDS I WAS
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT FOR BROADBAND
EQUIPMENT GRANTS WITH THE EXPAT
EXPECTATIONS AT THAT TIME THAT
TWO MILLION OF THAT FIVE
MILLION WOULD SUPPORT
CONNECTION UP FOR PUBLIC
LIBRARIES. WHO LACK ACCESS FOR
BROADBAND NETWORKS AND THREE
MILLION OF THOSE FUNDS WHAT
EXPAND CAPACITY FOR LIBRARIES
ALREADY CONNECTED AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EXPECTATIONS
OUTLINED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT REMAIN UNCHANGED FOR
THE REMAINING FINDS. COULD YOU
AT HOME I'M SORRY COULD YOU
TELL ME WHAT THAT MEANS. DOES
THAT MEAN THAT YOU'RE TARGETING
THE ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ORIGINAL
PURPOSE JUST CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEND TOWARD THAT
ORIGINAL PURPOSES AT WHICH
ATTRACT. LIBRARIES THANK YOU.
AND THEN FOR SCENIC LET ME JUST
ASK WITH THEIR PROBLEM AND
PROVIDING FINANCIAL INFORMATION
TO THE L. A. L. NO WE CAN
FOLLOW UP AND TRY THEM FOR
THEIR INFORMATION. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THEN LET ME THANK
THAT THE PANEL WE APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING HERE SORRY FOR THE
QUICKNESS OF THE HEARING. AND-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM. THE PANEL IS
CHEN KACU FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ELLIE GARDNER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CAROLINE'S ACREE. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
THERE WE THINK THERE'S A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. WHICH APPARENTLY IS A
DRAFT CHOICE TO BE NAMED SO I
WILL FIGURE OUT WHO THAT IS
WHEN. POLICY WAS SET THERE SO
I'M ASSUMING THAT'S WHO IT IS
OKAY- THEN WE WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS JENNIFER
COPY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE CALIFORNIA DAHLE
EDUCATION PROGRAM PROVIDES
CITIZENSHIP TRAINING AND
EDUCATION TO IMPROVE LITERACY
KILLED EMPLOYABILITY AND
PARENTING ABILITIES TO ADULTS-
I PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL AND
UNIFIED DISTRICT. I DON'T
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ALSO MEET
THE SPECIAL NEEDS OF THE
DISABLED AGING POPULATIONS AND
NON OR LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKING
ABOUT. THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL EIGHT POINT ONE
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
REFLECT A ONE POINT 5% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES
A ONE MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR PURPOSES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM. AND SIXTEEN YOU DON'T
EDUCATION PROGRAM RECEIVED FIVE
MILLION. YOU FOR A THREE YEAR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT CONTRACT.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES THE AT THIS
INVESTMENT TO PROVIDE NECESSARY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR ADULTS
ADULT EDUCATION PROVIDER
PROVIDERS. SUCH AS HOSTING
STATEWIDE WEBINARS PROVIDING
WORKSHOPS AND ANNUAL SUMMIT AND
RESPONDING TO OTHER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACROSS. CALIFORNIA
DAHLE EDUCATION PROGRAM STARTS
BONNEVAL ADULT POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME WHERE
THE STATE IS LOOKING TO REBUILD
THE ECONOMY AND THE PAIR ADULTS
TO RE ENTER THE WORKFORCE. MY
COLLEAGUE MICHELLE KNEW AND I
WILL BE ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OF THEN WILL MOVE TO
ELLIE GARDNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. OF EDUCATION
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
THANK YOU CHAIR GARNER AND YOU
HAVE TO THE TO BRING. PUBLICANS
I DON'T EDUCATE- IN. STARTED IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX IN THE CAPE
K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM WITH
THE SCHOOL PER SCHOOL FOR
ADULTS OPEN BY SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL BOARD. SINCE THAT TIME
APPROXIMATELY 75% OF ADULT
PROGRAMS ARE IN THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. LEGAL
EDUCATION SYSTEM IS SUPPORTED
BY SEVERAL FUNDING STREAMS THE
FEDERAL WORKFORCE INNOVATION
AND OPPORTUNITY ACT WE- IN
SPECIFICALLY ENTITLED TO AND
ADMINISTERED BY THE CT. ALONG
WITH FUNDS. FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NON CREDIT PROGRAMS
COMMUNITY AT THE STATE FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION AND A
LIBRARY LIST LITERACY PROGRAMS.
THAT WE OWE A PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDER IN THE
COUNTRY PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING TO ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA. CITIES
ADULT EDUCATION OFFICE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE JOINTLY
ADMINISTERED THE ADULT
EDUCATION. PROGRAM PROVIDING
ADULT EDUCATION SERVICES TO
REGIONAL CONSERVE CONSORTIA
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THESE
FUNDS ARE PROVIDED THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE GRANT IN A THREE
YEAR CYCLE AND SUB GRANTEES ARE
REIMBURSED FROM THE CITY.
THERE'S ALSO THE STATE'S CAL
STATE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
PROGRAM. THAT FUNDS SUPPORT AT
THE END THOSE FUNDS SUPPORT KEY
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION. ADULT
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SPECIFICALLY THE NON CREDIT
PROGRAMS AND SOME SOME SERVICES
SUCH AS TRANSITION COUNSELORS.
KEEP YOUR TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS
RECEIVE OVER 88% OF THESE
FUNDS. AS A NOTE IN THE AGENDA
ITEMS APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY
PROVIDED TO THE STATE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR NON
CREDIT PROGRAMS. IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THE STATE WIDE
LEADERSHIP ACTIVITIES PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
PROGRAM EVALUATION FOR ADULT
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM. WHICH
SERVE OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ADULT EDUCATION
STUDENTS THE CD E. REQUESTS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER PROVIDING THE CITY
WITH A MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FUNDS STARTING IN IN THE UP
COMING FISCAL YEAR OF TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. TO CONTINUE
PERFORMING THESE. DUTIES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF FIVE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WAS A- FOR
THREE FROM TWO SIXTY TO TWO
NINETEEN. AND ENDED IN DECEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE CITY WOULD
NEED THIS FUNDING STREAM TO
CONTINUE THAT TA AND T. AND P.
D. NEEDED FOR THE STATE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS CONTINUED
SUCCESS. ADDITIONALLY THE CITY
WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER PROVIDING THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO KOLA. FOR
CALIFORNIA DAHLE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AT THE SAME LEVEL OF
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE LCF
COLLAB THREE POINT EIGHT FOUR
PERCENT. THE ADULT SCHOOLS
SIMILAR TO OTHER CATER TO ALL
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACT BY THE INCREASED COSTS
FOR SCHOOLS TO SAFELY REOPEN
ARE FACING SIMILAR COST
PRESSURES. AS THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDE CD
IS REMARKS AND I HAVE WITH ME
DR CAROLYN ZACHARY OF THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER TRANSITIONS
DIVISION AT CD WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S.
OFFICE WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SENATORS. IN GET MORE.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION MY
NAME IS LIZ THAT NEVER AT. AND
I'M THE VICE CHANCELLOR OF
COLLEGE FINANCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES. SINCE
ITS INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION THAT
CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM HAS CONTINUED TO A
BALL. OVER THE LAST ELEVEN
MONTHS AS WAS SHARED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
PROGRAMS AND BOTH THE K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
BEEN CHALLENGED. BUT THROUGH
THIS COMPLEX PERIOD WE'VE
LEARNED THAT CALIFORNIANS NEED
US MORE THAN EVER. WELL A
COMPLETE ANALYSIS IS STILL
MONTHS AWAY. SOME INITIAL
FINDINGS INDICATE THAT IN
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN HAVE TURNED
TO OUR PROGRAMS FOR DIGITAL
LITERACY OR TO GAIN ACCESS TO
SUPPORT SERVICES. WE ARE ALSO
SEEING INTERESTS AND SHORT TERM
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATIONS
GROW. OUR PROGRAMS ARE AN
IMPORTANT SAFETY NET WHICH CAN
PROPEL ADULTS TO GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THIS REASON
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT PROVIDING A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA THE BILL
EDUCATION PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY
GIVEN THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO
TEACHING AND LEARNING
MODALITIES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR ONE MILLION AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT COULD
NOT BE MORE TIMELY. A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE PROGRAM
APPORTIONMENT HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED WITH GUIDANCE TO
DEVELOP SPENDING OVER THIRTY
MONTHS. AND BASED ON OUR MOST
RECENT FISCAL ANALYSIS OVERALL
CARRYOVER IS ONLY AT 10% AND
EXPECTED TO DECLINE TO AROUND
4% IN THE COMING MONTHS.
FINALLY THE TEAMSTERS OFFICE
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. MADE OTHER
PROGRESS TO ENSURING TIMELY
ALLOCATION OF ANNUAL RESOURCES.
TO AS WE PLAN FOR THE STATE'S
RECOVERY AND RESILIENCY WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT THE
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PIVOTAL. THANK
YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU AND I WAS
REMISS IN NOT MENTIONING WHEN I
LISTED TE PANELS. AT THE
OUTSET OF POSTING HOUSING FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND ALL RECOGNIZE HIM
NOW THANK YOU. THANK NUMBERS
PASTA HOUSING WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WITH REGARD TO
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
PROPOSAL WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS YEAH AUGMENTATION
COULD HELP ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS IN OPERATING THE
PROGRAMS. WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT RATE
THE COLOR RATE WHICH IS BASED
ON A PRICE INDEX FOR STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL BE
UPDATED IN APRIL WHEN THE STATE
RECEIVES ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC
DATA. AND WILL LIKELY SEE
REVISED RATE AT REVISED SO
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE A DECISION
ON THE CALL AT THAT TIME. WITH
REGARD TO THE PROPOSED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE STATEWIDE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
LEGISLATURE WILL JUST WANT TO
GET CLARIFICATION ON WHETHER
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND CD.
INTEND TO PUT OUT A REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS AND OUR OUR ESSAY
SO THAT YOU MANY COLLEGES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES. OF EDUCATION CAN
OPENLY BID ON THIS CONTRACT
THAT'S HOW ZAC COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WAS SELECTED TO DO
THE WORK BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHESTER'S OFFICE
WAS PLANNING TO AUTOMATICALLY
WE AWARD THE CONTRACT TO THE
SAC COUNTY OFFICE OF BAD THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO DIRECT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO USE
THE RFA PROCESS. DOING SO COULD
HELP IDENTIFY OR CONFIRM THE
BEST CONTRACTOR SUITABLE FOR
THIS PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE PANELISTS I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS THE FIRST ONE LET
ME JUST FOLLOW UP ON WHAT THE
L. A. O. JUST SAID WITH THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE DO YOU HAVE A CLEAR
INTENT WITH REGARD TO GOING OUT
FOR THAT CONTRACT. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION NO FINAL
DECISION HAS BEEN MADE IN THIS
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD CONSULT WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- WHEN
AND IF THESE RESOURCES. DO MAKE
IT INTO THE BUDGET ACT. OKAY I
JUST THINK THERE'S INTEREST IN
WHATEVER THE DECISION IS AND
THEN SECONDLY FROM. I THINK IT
WAS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THAT
MENTIONED- THAT DATA ISN'T
TOTALLY AND YET TO ACCEPT FOR.
OF THAT FOR HER CLASSES WERE UP
IN CAREER AND TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND- ONE OTHER THING
AND SO MY QUESTION IS THERE ANY
WAY AT THIS POINT TWO WITH DATA
TO ASSESS THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON ADULT EDUCATION.
BERMAN ROMAN DATA I MEAN
OVERALL WE'VE SEEN ENROLLMENTS-
IT KIND OF DECLINE STATEWIDE
AND SO WE SEE A DECLINE AROUND
THE SAME RATE THAT- IT'S
DECLINED FOR. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND PRESUMABLY FOR-
FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS OUR FINAL
ANALYSIS TYPICALLY COMES IN
FROM OUR COLLEGES AROUND- MARCH
APRIL AND SPRING WE ALSO GET
MORE DETAILS AROUND THE TYPES
OF ENROLLMENT. AS A REFERENCE
ONE AREA THAT WE HAVE SEEN
INTEREST- IS AROUND DIGITAL
LITERACY PROGRAM SO WILL WANT
TO DO A DEEPER DIVE INTO THAT
AND SEE. WHY THAT IS OF
INTEREST ONE PRESUMPTION IS
THAT AS MORE PARENTS ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH THEIR STUDENTS AT
HOME- THEY ALSO HAVE INTEREST
IN GAINING SKILLS IN THIS AREA.
AND WE'RE SEEINGMORE QUESTIONS
EMERGE AROUND SHORT TERM
PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE AN AREA
WHERE COLLEGES ANARCHY TOLD
PROGRAMS CAN ADAPT THAT WE MEET
OUR DEMAND OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
THEN LET ME ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION- BECAUSE I'M REALLY
FAMILIAR WITH ENROLLMENT ISSUES
AT THE THREE HIGHER EDUCATION
BRANCHES IN K. TO TWELVE. BUT
I'M NOT SURE I THINK YOU JUST
SAID ENROLLMENT WAS OFF AND SO
OFTEN ROMANS OFF HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT THE FISCAL SITUATION DO
THEY HAVE FUNDS LEFT. THAT THEN
WOULD ADDRESS THESE OTHER NEEDS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- WHAT'S
THE FISCAL SITUATION THAT
RESULTS. FROM A DROP OFF IN
ENROLLMENT. YES THANK YOU GREAT.
OF LINE A GAY TWELVE. HOUR
CALLER- WE'VE INTO- TITLE FIVE
EMERGENCY ALLOWANCES WHICH
PROTECT OF COLLEGES FROM
ENROLLMENT DECLINES IN ANY
SUBSEQUENT OFFICE SCHOOL
RESOURCE DECLINE SO THAT IS
PROVIDING A LEVEL OF FISCAL
STABILITY THAT IS HELPING OUR
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS- AND I
CAN- I WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO HIGHLIGHT HOW
THEY'VE HANDLED ANY. FISCAL
DECLINE ON THE K. TWELVE LEVEL.
AT SIX SIX CHAIRMAN- A COUPLE
NOTES BEFORE I HAND OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CAROLINE ZACHARY WHO
IS THE EXPERT IN THIS AREA THE
FIRST NEW IS THAT- WE HAVE SEEN
INCREASES IN HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIPMENTS EQUIVALENCY BUT A
DECLINE IN LOW LEVEL LITERACY
STUDENTS AND SO WHAT I'M GONNA
DO IS HANDED OVER TO CAROLINE
TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
OVERVIEW OF THAT DATA THAT WE
DO HAVE THAT YOU'VE BEEN ASKING
ABOUT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN. DR CAROLINE ZACHRY
ADULT EDUCATION ADMINISTRATOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. WE HAVE SEEN WHEN
WE COMPARE OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY DATA IN THE
VERY FIRST QUARTER TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
YEAH WE HAVE SEEN A DECLINE IN.
ROUGHLY. 675-200-1000 STUDENTS
ENROLLMENT AND THIS STATE IS
COMING OUT OF- ALL OF THE K.
TWELVE ADULTS SCHOOLS IN ANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE NONCREDIT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WE LA
AGENCIES BECAUSE THEY ARE
IMPORTING INTO. OUR DATA SYSTEM
CALLED COST SAYS WHICH IS-
WHICH GIVES IS LIVE. ANSWERABLE
TO SEE THAT DECLINE. OKAY WELL
I THANK YOU WILL BE INTERESTED
IN THAT ISSUE HEADING TOWARD
THE MAY REVISED JUST TO SEE.
WHAT THE ACTUAL SITUATION IS
WHETHER IT NEEDS TO BE REGARDED
TO THESE EMERGING AIDS OR HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE HANDLED SO I
THINK THAT'LL BE ONE THING WORK
INTEREST SENATOR MEANT YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE.
GREAT THE MEN ARE LET ME THANK
THE PANELISTS WE APPRECIATE-
YOU BEING HERE AND WE ARE GOING
TO- MOVE. TO- ISSUE SIX SEVEN
AND EIGHT AND SIX IS THE
FEDERAL STUDENT AID PROPOSAL
SEVEN IS CAL GRANT A COLLEGE
BUILDING EIGHT IS PRIVATE
NONPROFIT SECTOR PROFIT SECTOR
CAL GRANT AND ALEX GRAVES FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES WAS AND
UNIVERSITIES WAS GOING TO SPEAK
TO ISSUE EIGHT AND IT'S THE
SAME PANELISTS OTHERWISE FOR
THE THREE ISSUES SO WHY ARE YOU
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE BEING
CONSIDERED SEPARATELY IN OUR
GENDER AND BUDGETARY LEAST WE
WILL HAVE THE PRESENTATIONS
TOGETHER AND ASK QUESTIONS
TOGETHER. AND SO THE PANELISTS
WILL BE PROPER OUR CHAVEZ FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CHECK
BERMAN- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION ALEX
GRAVES AND THEN LISA KING FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MORNING
CHAIR. COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
SENATOR MAN AT LIKE THOMAS THE
DEPARTMENT- FINANCE- ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WE HAVE THE FIVE
SOLUTION OUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A STATUTE TO
REQUIRE ALL HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
TO COMPLETE FOSSA OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION. BEGINNING IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ACADEMIC YEAR. THE STATE HAS
SEEN THE CLIENTS OF ROUGHLY 10%
AND 45% IN FIRST TIME FRESHMEN
FAST SAT. EIGHT ADVOCATE
APPLICATIONS. I CALIFORNIA
DREAMIN UP WE CAN. OF THIS
STUFF WILL EACH THAT STUDENTS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
THE MAXIMUM FINANCIAL EIGHT TO
PURSUE A HIGHER EDUCATION. THEN
I'M GONNA MOVE ON ITEM SEVEN
WHICH WE HAVE THE COGNATE- THE
CALDERON PROGRAM AT THE STATE'S
LARGEST IN FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM. IS SUSPECTED TO SERVE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND PROVIDE
MORE THAN TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION EIGHT EIGHT. THIS
TOTALS INCLUDE REVISED COCHRAN
ESTIMATES OF THE NUMBER OF NEW
AND RENEWAL COCHRAN AWARDEES IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
THE GOVERNOR'S DIDN'T FIFTY
EIGHT POINT TWO. MILLION
ONGOING FUND TO RESTORE CALM
ELIGIBLE. FOR STUDENTS IMPACT
BY CHANGE IN LIVES INSTEAD DE
TO THE CALL NINETEEN. AND WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE LAW THEIR
COVERAGE AWARD. LASTLY ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT OUT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT AS INDICATED IN THE
H. AND THAT CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS. TO OFFER
ADMISSION TO AT LEAST THREE
THOUSAND ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
MAXIMAL CAGR IN TUITION AWARD.
FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS. I NINE
THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS.
THE GRAND AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO AMEND THE
STATUTE TO THE LATE THIS
REQUIREMENT FROM APPLY NEED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
APPLY IN IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. THIS PROPOSAL
WILL PROVIDE STABILITY TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE CONTEMPLATING
ATTENDING A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION AND DOES CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION. THANK YOU AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- JAKE
BRUNNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION WELCOME AND
SUPPORT EACH OF THESE THREE
PROPOSALS ALL BRIEFLY SPEAK TO
EACH OF THEM. ON THE FINANCIAL
AID COMPLETION REQUIREMENT WITH
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
UNDERSTAND WELL THE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER THAT THESE APPLICATIONS
THEMSELVES CAN POSE TO STUDENTS
AS THEY SEEK FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO PURSUE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION THE CURRENT
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
FEATURE OVER ONE HUNDRED
QUESTIONS MANY OF WHICH USE
VERY TECHNICAL LANGUAGE I'M
AROUND TAXES ADJUSTED GROSS
INCOME. THEY CAN BE VERY
UNFAMILIAR TO STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY FROM FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GOING
FAMILIES. AND WE ALSO KNOW FROM
OUR OWN DATA THAT THERE'S A
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
EACH YEAR WHO ARE NOT APPLYING
FOR FINANCIAL AID WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE THIS
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES BEING LEFT ON THE
TABLE THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO THEM TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION. INCLUDING FEDERAL
FUNDS. PROVIDED THROUGH THE
PELL GRANT PROGRAM. WE'RE AT
THE EXISTING COMMISSION WE'RE
VERY PROUD ADMINISTER SEVERAL
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT SEEK TO
HELP STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
COMPLETE THE APPLICATIONS FOR
FINANCIAL AID. I BELIEVE THAT
THESE CAN BE IMPORTANT
RESOURCES TO OUR PARTNERS IN K.
TWELVE AS THEY WOULD IMPLEMENT
THIS REQUIREMENT SHOULD BE
ADOPTED IN THE BUDGET ACT. ON
THE CAL GRANT A- ELIGIBILITY
RESTORATION AGAIN WE SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL AT THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH
OUR SEGMENT PARTNERS REGARDING
THIS AND OTHER ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN CREATED BY THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM TO PROVIDE
THIS RELIEF TO STUDENTS SHOULD
BE PROVIDED. AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. THERE'S BEEN SOME
CHANGE IN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ESTIMATED TO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THIS ISSUE OUR
CAMPUS PARTNERS IN SEGMENT
REPRESENTATIVES WOULD BE IN A
BETTER POSITION. TO SPEAK TO
THAT- THE CURRENT STATUS IN THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IMPACTED. AS THE PROCESS
FURNISHING INITIATING THIS
CHANGE AND LIVING STATUS
ACTUALLY BEGINS. AT THE CAMPUS
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE LEVEL AND
WE'VE BEEN RECEIVED THAT DATA
THROUGH WHAT'S CALLED A CRACK
RECORD CHANGE FORM AT THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. AND I
COULD SHARE MORE IN TERMS OF
THE DATA WE'VE RECEIVED THUS
FAR THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. AND
FINALLY ON THE FINAL THE THIRD
PROPOSAL WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE
THE COMMISSIONWOULD AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS YOU FOR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
WOULD NOT BE HELPFUL TO OUR
STUDENTS TO SEE. ANY DISRUPTION
TO THEIR ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
AID. DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THIS PERIOD OF SUCH UNCERTAINTY
FOR STUDENTS AND- A YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL MOVE TO
OUR GRAVES FROM ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. THANK YOU
CHEN MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS
PRIVATE NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES
WORK ON IMPROVING TRANSFER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS. I
AM JUST SPEAKING- TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT ON THE AGENDA. WE
ACC YOU SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
PUSH OUT THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS YEAR
GIVEN THE HISTORIC DESTRUCTION
WE HAVE SEEN FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES FOR INSTITUTIONS AND
FOR THE STATE. THESTATUTORY
CONSTRUCT IS BORN OUT A DESIRE.
ADMINISTRATION CDT PATHWAYS
EXPANDED INTO OUR SECTOR AND
OUR INSTITUTIONS EMBRACE THAT
OPPORTUNITY SINCE THE AGREEMENT
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET THIRTY NINE AT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ARTICULATED UNTIL HE'S TWENTY
T. PATHWAY MEANING THAT THE
MAJORITY OF FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE THAT
EXCEPT THE AT T. ARE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES. HAS YOUR
GENDER NOTES LAST YEAR WE HAD
OVER TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY T. STUDENTS ADMITTED TO
OUR PARTICIPATING INSTITUTIONS
EXCEEDING OUR STATUTORY TARGET.
AND AS OF THE LAST ACADEMIC
YEAR WE NOW HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN ARTICULATED AT
T. PATHWAYS TO OUR INSTITUTIONS.
IN NOVEMBER WE SURVEYED OUR
ADMISSIONS OFFICES WITH FIFTY
SIX INSTITUTIONS RESPONDING WHO
COLLECTIVELY AND ROLL ABOUT 91%
OF OUR TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. A
SURVEY FINDINGS REVEALED A 7%
DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT OVERALL
AND A 6% DECLINE AMONG TRANSFER
STUDENT ROMAN. WE ALSO LOOKED
SPECIFICALLY AT THE RESPONSES
OF R. EIGHTY T. PARTICIPATING
INSTITUTIONS AND FOUND THAT THE
DECLINE FOR THEIR TRANSFER
STUDENT ROLE THAT WAS AROUND
SIX AND A HALF PERCENT. SO
WHILE WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
DATA COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS
FOR THIS ACADEMIC YEAR'S AT T.
ADMITS THOSE SURVEY FINDINGS
CERTAINLY LEAD US TO BELIEVE
THAT THE PANDEMIC MAY ADVERSELY
AFFECT OUR AT T. NUMBERS THIS
YEAR. AND POTENTIALLY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS INTO THE FUTURE.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS
WOULD BE AN ACCURATE REFLECTION
OF THE SECTOR'S COMMITMENT AT
T. AND TO THE STUDENTS WHO USE
THAT PATHWAY. AND SO WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT
RECOGNIZES THE DOCUMENT AND
REMAINS WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
EARLY ASSURANCES TO STUDENTS.
AS WAS MENTIONED I BELIEVE BY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN WILL HAVE THE L. A. O.
MORNING CHEN SENATOR IS LOOKING
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. OCTOBER THE FIFTH
PUZZLES IN THAT ORDER THEY
PAYING YOUR GENDER BEGINNING
DAD THE PROPOSAL'S PAID FOR
GAUGE AND. WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUIRING TO CONFIRM THE ALL
STATE SENATE FINANCIALLY
APPLIQUE AS A PROBLEM APPROACH
TO INCREASE FINANCIAL TO OBTAIN.
INCLUDING THE FACT PROGRAM
PROGRAM ASSISTANT AID
COMMISSION NOTED. COM SUCH A
PACKAGE IF YOU'RE KINDA. ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED FISCAL. ISSUES FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
ONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TRY
ATTENTION TO IS AN ACCOUNT AND
ENTITLE PROGRAM. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS HAS ITS INTENDED
EFFECT OF INCREASING FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION RATES MORE
STUDENTS WILL BE CONSIDERED FOR
ENTITLEMENT AWARDS AND WE
EXPECT THIS TO LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN ENTITLEMENT
SPENDING BEGINNING AT TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR.
THIS IS SOMETHING I WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE PLAN
FOR WORK AT ALL DISPOSAL.
ATTENTION FISCAL IMPASSE ON
THAT PAUL SIDE OF THE BY. AS
YOU MAY KNOW WELL IS THE
SUPPOSED AWAY NOT IN THE- TECH.
MANDATE THE STATE WOULD NEED TO
COVER THE ASSOCIATED COSTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THE WAY THE
CURRENT. LANGUAGES WRITTEN
DISTRICTS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
DISCRETION OVER HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THE RULES SO. THAT
MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT
TO ANTICIPATE WHAT THE COST
MIGHT BE. RECOMMENDED OPTING
FALLS ON HOW. AS IT IS A PROM
WAITING. FINANCIAL AID UP. BUT
WE ALSO RECOMMEND WITH THE- ON
THE SPECIFIC TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT IT
DOESN'T IMPOSE ANY UNNECESSARY
COSTS DISTRICTS AND- THAT IT
ADDRESSES ANY OTHER
IMPLEMENTATION CONSENSUS JUST
LIKE JIMMY. THANKS TO THE
COMPANY ELIGIBILITY RESTORATION
PROPOSAL WHICH APPEARS ON PGE
TWENTY VERY DONDE. I DO PROVIDE
SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND ON THIS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT IS A NEW
ISSUE EMERGING THIS YEAR DURING
THE PANDEMIC. WE KNOW THAT IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT
STUDENTS NEED TO DEMONSTRATE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF FINANCIAL
NEED. BASED ON HOW CAMPUS IS
CALCULATED STUDENTS FINANCIAL
NEED. INTENSELY HIGHER FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WERE LIVING ON
CAMPUS AND STUDENTS WERE LIVING
AT HOME WITH FAMILY. BECAUSE
CAMPUSES THIS YEAR LARGELY
OPERATING REMOTELY WERE SEEN
MANY STUDENTS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE LIVED IN THE
DORMS ARE INSTEAD LIVING AT
HOME WITH FAMILY. AND A NUMBER
OF THOSE STUDENTS HAVE LOST
THEIR **** AN ELIGIBILITY AS
INSULTS. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY DRESSES AS
UNINTENDED EFFECT. AND WHAT
CAMPUS IS OPERATING REMOTELY WE
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO HAVE MOVED HOME TO
THE PANDEMIC TO RECEIVE THE
TUITION COVERAGE THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE RECEIVED HAD THEY
LIVED ON CAMPUS. BUT MORE GIVEN
THE STUDENTS HAVE HAD THEIR
WORDS ARE DRAWN IN THE CURRENT
YEAR- TAKING EARLY ACTION THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF RESTORING THAT EXPENSIVE-
YOU NEED COMMISSION HAS NOTED
THERE HAS BEEN A CHANGE IN THE
ESTIMATED NUMBER OF IMPACTED
STUDENTS. AND BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING
LEVELS FIFTY EIGHT MILLION IS
BASED ON ESTIMATES PROVIDED BY
THE SECONDS THE FALL. WE EXPECT
THAT MORE RECENT DATA ON THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE TO A LOWER
COST ESTIMATE. AND SO WHAT WE
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE ALSO
RECOMMEND REVISITING THE
FUNDING LEVEL SENSITIVE THIS
PROPOSAL THE MAYOR VISION. ONE
UPDATED DATA MAY BE AVAILABLE
ON THE NUMBER OF IMPACTED
STUDENTS. BUT A LITTLE. WE ON
THE PROPOSAL REGARDING THE
TRANSFER TARGET FOR THE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. ICAC SEARS
NOTED THE SECTOR HAS
EXPERIENCED A MOMENT DECLINES
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND AS A
RESULT THERE'S A RISK THEY
MIGHT MISS THEIR
TRANSFORMATIONS TARGET FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR WHICH WOULD RESULT
IN A REDUCTION IN AWARD AMOUNTS
FOR STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL
NEED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
PREVENT THIS CONTRADICTION WHAT
AMOUNTS FOR THESE INCOMING
STUDENTS. PROMOTING EARLY
ACTION ON THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF FIGHTING
THE STUDENTS MORE
PREDICTABILITY REGARDING A
FINANCIALLY COVERAGE AS THE
MAKING ALL THE DECISIONS THIS
SPRING. AND SO WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL.
THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
TO ALL OF YOU AND FOR DRESSING
ALL THREE ITEMS- I THINK W
MIGHT. HAVE DRAWN SOME WARM.
THINGS OUT IF WE HAD MORE TIME
BUT I AM GOING TO ASK ONE
QUESTION- OF- JAKE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND THAT'S THAT IN
YOUR- TESTIMONY. THAT
MENTIONED. HOW SHE SAT QUARTER
NIGHTS WITH THE LOCAL AGENT.
EDUCATION AGENCIES IN ASSISTING
THE STUDENTS WITH FILLING OUT
FINANCIAL AID FORMS AND- HOW
SOMETIMES THAT. WHICH IS THAT
NOT WORKING LEADS TO A LOSS. I
WAS WONDERING IF THERE'S- A
CHANGE IN COORDINATION
ANTICIPATED TO UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL OR WHETHER YOU'RE JUST
REALLY. IDENTIFYING A LONG
STANDING PROBLEM AND JUST
TRYING TO ADDRESS IT IN A MORE
STRONGER CONCERTED WHY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR A GREAT
QUESTION AND I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THEY SPOKE PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A MORE
SYSTEMIC APPROACH FOR OUR STATE
AND HELPING STUDENTS APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID AND SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE THOSE APPLICATIONS.
AND GRADUATE WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE THAT TO THEM SHOULD
THEY WISH TO PURSUE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. AS PART OF
THAT MORE SYSTEMIC APPROACH
WE'RE ASSESSING AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION HOW WE CAN
ORIENT OUR OUTREACH PROGRAMS TO
BEST SUPPORT OUR K. TWELVE
PARTNERS IN IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROVISION SHOULD BE
ADOPTED- WE WERE IN FACT- CAN.
ONE THREE LEGISLATION THIS YEAR
TO UPDATE THE AUTHORIZATION FOR
OUR KELSO PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT OPPORTUNITY
AND ACCESS PROGRAM. IN WHICH
SIXTEEN REGIONALLY BASED
CONSORTIA PROVIDE FINANCIAL AID
OUTREACH AND TUTORING SERVICES
TO DISADVANTAGED K. TWELVE
STUDENTS- TO INCREASE THEIR
ACCESS TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. AND INFORM STUDENTS
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES- FOR CAREER
EDUCATION AS WELL AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE PROJECTS AS
WELL AS OUR CASH FOR COLLEGE
WORKSHOPS. AND AGREES TO SUBMIT
CAMPAIGN THAT WE LAUNCHED IN
RECENT YEARS CAN ALL BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN SUPPORTING OUR
K. TWELVE PARTNERS IN
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING THIS
REQUIREMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL- CONTINUE TO BE
INTERESTED IN THAT AS WE ARE
GONE WRONG CENTER MEANT YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON SUN GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANKS
TO THE PANELISTS ALTHOUGH ONLY
ALEX GRAVES IS GOING AWAY.
WE'RE COMING BACK TO ISSUES
NINE AND TEN WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR PRESENTATIONS TOGETHER
ON IT'S TO COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT AND FOSTER YOUTH CAL
GRANT. AND WE'LL BE HEARING
FROM GABRIELA CHAVEZ TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JAKE
BERMAN- AGAIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND LISA CAME FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SO HELLO WE WILL BE
CONSIDERING THOSE TWO TOGETHER
WILL BEGIN WITH GABRIELA
SANCIOUS. HEY EVERYONE CHáVEZ
BUT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HOW
THE COUPLE. CALL GRANT PROGRAM
SUPPORTS FINANCIAL AID AWARDS
FOR STUDENTS WHO DEMONSTRATE
FINANCIAL NEED BUT DID NOT MEET
ALL THE CRITERIA TO RECEIVE AN
ENTITLEMENT OF WATER. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FIVE MILLION I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND TO FIND NINE
THOUSAND CALL GRAND COMPETITIVE
AWARDS. THIS WILL INCREASE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
AWARDS. TO FIFTY THOUSAND. ALSO
THE GOVERNOR'S BY GETTING A
TWENTY MILLION AND GOING
GENERAL FINE DOING CRAZY
ACCESSIBLE FOR FORMER OR
CURRENT FOSTER YOU. ELIGIBLE AT
NEW ALREADY ALL CONQUERING THE
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE AN AXIS
AWARD. SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS NEW
ALREADY WILL CALL GRAHAM B.
STUDENTS WILL SEE THEIR ACCESO
WERE INCREASED FROM ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT. TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
AN ELIGIBLE CONCORD NC STUDENTS
WILL SEE THEIR BOOKS AND SUPPLY
WERE INCREASED FROM.
1-000-942-4000 DOLLARS THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BAR THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
CHECK BERMAN- FROM THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. THANK YOU
MISTER. UP WE HAD THIS AID
COMMISSION ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S PROPOSED AN EXPANSION
OF THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT AWARDS AVAILABLE FOR
THE UPCOMING YEAR. THIS WOULD
ALLOW US AT THE COMMISSION TO
SERVE MORE BE ELIGIBLE BUT
UNFUNDED STUDENTS THAT ARE
REFERENCED IN YOUR AGENDA
MATERIALS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THERE WERE OVER TWO
HUNDRED NINETY THREE THOUSAND
APPLICANTS THAT WERE REFERRED
TO A COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT COOL
IT ONLY FORTY ONE THOUSAND
AWARDS THAT THE COMMISSION WAS
AUTHORIZED TO PAY TO STUDENTS.
ONLY ONE FOR EVERY SEVEN
STUDENTS IN THE COMPETITIVE
SCHOOL RECEIVED A GRANT AS A
RESULT. OF OR PUT ANOTHER WAY
86% OF STUDENTS IN THE
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM DESPITE
HAVING SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
NEED WILL NOT RECEIVE ANY CAL
GRANT WORK. WITHOUT EXPANSION.
THE COMMISSION IS GRATEFUL FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AND VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS INVESTMENT.
THE COMMISSION WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT THIS STILL LEAVES MANY
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WITHOUT
AB NOR WOULD IT PROVIDE ANY
PREDICTABILITY MORE CERTAINTY
TO THE STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
ACTUALLY RECEIVE AN AWARD.
THESE NINE THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
AWARDS ARE A WELCOME INVESTMENT
IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET BUT WE
ARE HOPING THAT MOVING FORWARD
UNDER CAL GRANT MODERNIZATION
WHICH WE'LL DISCUSS. IN A FEW
AGENDA ITEMS HERE THAT WE CAN
ELIMINATE ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
THAT RESULT IN SO MANY STUDENTS
BEING PLACED IN A COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM. IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
PROVIDE OUR MOST FINANCIALLY
VULNERABLE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH MORE
PREDICTABLE ACCESS TO STATE
FINANCIAL AID. IN REGARDS TO BE
CAL GRANT ACCESS AWARD FOR
FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL AT WE
ALSO WELCOME THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE RESOURCES
IDENTIFIED TO SERVICE STUDENT
POPULATION THAT WE KNOW FACES
SO MANY ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
AND THE PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INCLUDING A LACK OF
FAMILY RESOURCES TO DRAW UPON.
AS THEY TRIED TO PAY FOR
COLLEGE. WE APPRECIATE THAT
EXPANDING ACCESS TO AID FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
HAS BEEN A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL EVIDENCED
BY SEVERAL RECENT EFFORTS- IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO
EXPAND. THE ELIGIBILITY PERIODS
FOR CURRENT OR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH RECEIVING AID. AND THE
COMMISSION IS ALSO PROUD TO
ADMINISTER THE CHIEF YOU
EDUCATION AND TRAINING DR GRANT
PROGRAM. A FEDERALLY AND STATE
FUNDED PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH WE
PROVIDE FINANCIAL AID ELIGIBLE
FOSTER YOUTH. AS IT RELATES TO
IMPLEMENTATION THE COMMISSION
WOULD NOTE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
A DATA MATCH PROCESS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
FOR PURPOSES OF VERIFYING THE
APPLICANT'S ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
GP GRANT PROGRAM THAT I JUST
MENTIONED. THIS WOULD HELP US
IN THE PROCESS OF CONFIRMING A
FINANCIALLY APPLICANTS
ELIGIBILITY FOR THIS ENHANCE
ACCESS AWARD WITHOUT CREATING
AN ADDITIONAL PROCESS UP FOR
THE STUDENT APPLYING. AND ALL
OF MY COMMENTS FOR NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU THEN WILL GO TO
THE L. A. R. THANK YOU. I'LL BE
IN THE COMPETITIVE TOP AND
WEBER. ASSISTED NEED COMMISSION
AS NOTED DEMAND FOR THIS
PROGRAM FAR EXCEEDS SUPPLY AND
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE WAY THIS
PROPOSAL IS STRUCTURED AS THAT
THE AWARDS ONE PROVIDED WOULD
BE LARGELY ALLOCATED ACCORDING
TO STUDENT NEED. THIS IS A
REFLECTION OF THE SCORING
MATRIX IS DENIED COMMISSION IS
TO PRIORITIZE STUDENTS FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANTS AND I MAKE A
COMPARISON PAGE TWENTY FOUR
GANDAK. THREE TWENTY FOUR CAN.
THAT WE WANTED TO NOTE. AND NOT
SET THE COSTS WOULD INCREASE IN
THE OUT YEARS THIS IS A PATTERN
WE COMMONLY SEE WHAT PROPOSALS
THAT IMPACT ONE INCOMING NEW
COHORT OF TARGET RECIPIENTS AT
A TIME. BASED ON DATA FROM THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND THAT
COSTS OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL COULD ROUGHLY DOUBLE
BY THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE FISCAL YEAR. WE
KNOW HIS BECAUSE WE ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP THE STATE'S
PROJECTED OPERATING DEFICIT IN
MIND AS YOU CONSIDER SENATE HOW
CAN EXTENSION. BUT PARTICULARLY
EXPANSION SUCH AS THIS ONE THAT
HAVE ESCALATING COSTS. IF THE
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE WE DO
THINK THIS PROPOSAL IS WORTH
CONSIDERING FOR THE REASONS
NOTED. IT IN FACT THE LINES
QUITE CLOSELY WITH RECENT
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO EXPAND
CONCORD ELIGIBILITY ACCORDING
TO STUDENT MEET. SUPPLEMENTAL
AWARDS FOR FOSTER YOUTH. THE
KEY BENEFIT WE SEE INNOCENT.
THAT WOULD TARGET ADDITIONAL
TUITION HE TOOK OF STUDENTS
WITH HIGH. NEED THERE ARE
COMMON STRUCTURES IS TRY EIGHT
IF YOU'RE TO WE DO RAISE ONE.
ISSUE HAVE FOR THE LARGEST TO
CAN. IN RECENT YEARS LARGEST
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
SIMPLIFYING THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WITH THE GOAL OF
MAKING IT EASIER FOR STUDENTS
TO NAVIGATE. CREATING A
SUPPLEMENTAL AWARD FOR SPECIFIC
STUDENT GROUPS COULD RUN
COUNTER TO HIS INTERESTS AND
SIMPLIFICATION. IN THE LONG
TERM WE THINK THERE COULD BE
SIMPLER MORE SYSTEMATIC OPTIONS
TO EXPANDING ON TUITION AID.
CURRENTLY AS YOU MAY KNOW WHILE
STUDENTS APPLY FOR FINANCIAL
AID ARE SIGNED SOMETHING CALLED
AN EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
OR ESC. THIS IS AN INDEX THAT'S
INTENDED TO MEASURE THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY FOR COLLEGE
BASED ON FACTORS SUCH AS THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES SIZE ASSETS.
STRUCTURE CURRENTLY THE SYNTAX
IS OF LIMITED USE IN
PRIORITIZING STUDENTS FOR
FINANCIALLY JUST BECAUSE SO
MANY STUDENTS ARE CLUSTERED IN
THE VERY LOWEST POSSIBLE VALUE.
BIAS VERY RECENT FEDERAL
LEGISLATION PASSED IN DECEMBER
HAS THAT INTEREST IN CHANGES TO
THIS MEASURE THAT WE THINK WILL
MAKE IT MORE USEFUL AND
PRIORITIZING THE VERY HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THE FUTURE
WHEN IT'S IMPLEMENTED IN THE
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR WORK ACT. SO WE KNOW THIS
BECAUSE WE THINK IT OPENS UP
THE POSSIBILITY OF USING THIS
IN TAX AS A MEANS TO PRIORITIZE
STUDENTS FOR NATIONAL AID
MOVING FORWARD. ULTIMATELY THE
LARGE CHOOSES TO GET HIGH BUT-
OUR PRIORITY TO TALK EXTENSION
THIS YEAR WE DO THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S. MERITS
CONSIDERATION AS IN YOUR TERM
OPTION TO EXPANDING IT FOR
GROUP OF STUDENTS VERY HIGH
NEED. BUT IN THE LONG TERM
WEARING COURAGE LEGISLATURE
EXPLORE. MORE SYSTEMATIC AND
BECOMES A MORE STREAMLINED
APPROACHES SUCH AS THE USE OF
AN AXE. THANK YOU AFTER TAKING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BOB I JUST WOULD NOTE THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ALL THE
TESTIMONY AND FEEL LIKE THAT'S-
WHAT WAS SAID WAS REALLY
EVIDENT IN WILL JUST TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. TOWARD THE MAY REVISE
BUT LET ME ASK. IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. THEN
I'M GOING TO IGNORE THAT WE'VE
BEEN JOINED BY SENATOR- CHOI
BOGUE. AND I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT. THAT SHE WAS AT HOUSING
COMMITTEE MEETING AND IT WAS A
LACK OF DESIRE. FOR BEING HERE
THAT SHE WASN'T HERE TILL NOW.
SO WHAT WE'RE GLAD SHE'S HERE.
BARM WE ARE COMBINING ISSUE
ELEVEN AND THIRTEEN TOGETHER
OUT OF THE GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS
INVOLVED- IT WAS A QUESTION OF
WHAT ORDER TO TAKE THINGS AND
DOES HAPPEN TO BE THE EXACT
THREE PANELISTS THAT ARE UP
THERE RIGHT NOW SO I THINK
WE'LL TAKE ISSUES. ELEVEN AND
THIRTEEN TOGETHER THE GRANT
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS AND THEN
WILL GO FOR FINAL ITEM BEING
THE FINANCIAL AID REFORM UPDATE
SO FOR ELEVEN AND THIRTEEN WE
HAVE THE GRANT DELIVERY SYSTEM
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS AND AGAIN
WE HAVE GABRIELA CHAVEZ JERRY
BREMNER AND LIESEGANG AND WILL
BEGIN WITH SCARBOROUGH CHAVEZ
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
DID INCLUDE Y. POINT EIGHT
MILLION. ONE TIME GENERAL FINE.
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETEEN THOUSAND
I'M GOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE FINAL PHASE OF THE
GRANT DELIVERY SYSTEM WELL THEN
THE STATION PROJECT AND I'M
GOING MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION
COSTS. THIS PROJECT IS
SCHEDULED TO BE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED BY APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- INCLUDES A STATUTORY
LANGUAGE TO AUTHORIZE THE
COMMISSION TO RECEIVE DONATIONS
BEQUESTS GRANTS AND
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDING SUBJECT
TO SUCH CONDITIONS OR
RESTRICTIONS AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMISSION.
MAYBE MY BICYCLE IS SUBJECT TO
THE APPROVAL OF THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE. THIS PROPOSAL OUT THE
RISE A COMMISSION TO DIRECTLY
RECEIVE DONATIONS AND MAXIMIZE
THE USE OF THESE FUNDS. ON A
WIDE RANGE OF PROJECTS. THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THEN WILL MOVE TO CHECK
BREMNER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE COMMISSION
REQUESTED THESE BONDS FOR THE
FINAL DAYS OF DEVELOPMENT AND
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
OF OUR GREAT DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT I'M
PLEASED TO REPORT THIS IS THE
COMMISSION SPINAL FUNDING
REQUEST ANTICIPATED FOR THIS
PROJECT. AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS THIS PROJECT
IN A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
COMMISSION DUE TO THE VOLUME
AND SENSITIVITY OF THE
APPLICATIONS WE PROCESS EACH
YEAR. AT EACH YEAR THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION RECEIVED AS MANY
AS TWO MILLION APPLICATIONS AND
APPROPRIATES TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN A- PRIOR TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE GRANT
DELIVERY SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
PROJECT. THE COMMISSION WAS
USING AN I. T. SYSTEM THAT WAS
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS OLD- TO
DO ALL THIS AND YOU CAN IMAGINE
THE RISKS THAT THAT POTENTIALLY
POSES TO THE STATE. THIS
PROJECT ALREADY SEEN MANY
FEATURES- THAT ARE BEING
UTILIZED ALREADY BY CORD USERS
INCLUDING MOST CRITICALLY OUR
STUDENTS- THOSE FEATURES ARE
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA MATERIALS
AND I'M- HAPPY TO EXPAND ON
THOSE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS- BUT- WE HAVE
LAUNCHED. SEVERAL DIFFERENT.
ITERATIONS OF OUR WEB GRANTS
PLATFORM FOR STUDENTS AS WELL
AS FOR SEVERAL OF OUR SPECIAL
PROGRAMS. THERE'S BEEN A DELAY
OF A FEW MONTHS TO ALLOW FOR
MORE THOROUGH TESTING DURING
THIS PERIOD. TO ENSURE THAT THE
RELEASE OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
FACING SIDE OF THE PROJECT IS
AS EFFECTIVE AND BUG FREE AS
POSSIBLE. AND AS NOTED IN THE
MATERIALS WE ANTICIPATE
LAUNCHING WEB GRANTS FOR
INSTITUTIONS IN APRIL OF THIS
YEAR. AND I'M ALSO JOINED BY
THE COMMISSION'S CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER DURING THE
PAINS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK ON THE- SORRY I
THOUGHT YOU WERE DONE- KEEP GO.
IT SHOULD BE A PHILANTHROPIC
FOR. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO LISA CAME
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU REGARDING THE
CANTABRI SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
PROPOSAL LAST THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION HAS NOTED THERE WAS
A RECENT SCHEDULE CHANGES AFEW
MONTHS FROM NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS YOU NEED
COMMISSION HAS ALREADY
SUBMITTED A SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO
REFLECT THIS CHANGE. OUR OFFICE
IS CURRENTLY WAITING TO RECEIVE
THE SUPPORT WHICH WE EXPECT TO
SEE IN THE COMING WEEKS WE
CONTRIBUTE TO STAND FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING SO
LINES WITH THE REVISED PROJECT
PLAN. ONCE ABOUT AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH OUR
STAFF WITH A RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS ITEM. REGARDING THE PHONE
TALK FUNDS. WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
IT'S BECAUSE AND CON. THE ONE
WE WOULD KNOW THAT IT DOES
CURRENTLY. PROVIDE FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER ADDING REQUIREMENT FOR
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
REPORT ANNUALLY AND ANY FUNDS
RECEIVED UNDER THE- COAST
AUTHORITY. JUST AS THIS WOULD
ALLOW IT TO MONITOR EXTERNALLY
FUNDED ACTIVITIES ENSURE THAT
THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE AS WELL AS
PUBLIC INTEREST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ALTHOUGH.
THEY I DO THINK THAT THE-
QUESTION OF A REPORT ON ISSUE
THIRTEEN IS- VALID ONE AND
MAYBE WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT THAT
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE MAY
REVISE. OR THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TENSING
NONE. ARE WILL MOVE TO THE
FINAL ITEM ON THE AGENDA- ISSUE
TWELVE WHICH IS THE CAL GRANT
TO REFORM UPDATE AND WE HAVE
MARLENE GARCIA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. AND
CHECK BREMNER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION COMING BACK AGAIN
SIR WELL WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND JUST
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME- I'LL BE
PRESENTING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH AN UPDATE ON
OUR EFFORTS TO MODERNIZE THE
CAL GRANT SYSTEM- THIS PROJECT
HAS IN FACT BEEN YEARS IN THE
MAKING AND AT THE URGING OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT. AND THEIR
CALL ON THE STATE TO FIX
FINANCIAL AID BY ADDRESSING THE
GROWING CHALLENGES NON TUITION
COSTS AND REMOVING THE
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS THAT I
REFERENCED PREVIOUSLY TO KEEP
SO MANY STUDENTS. OUT OF STATE
FINANCIAL AID. THE OUTBREAK OF
KOBE NINETEEN OUR STUDENTS WERE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO COVER
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. FOOD AND
HOUSING IN ADDITION TO OTHER.
NON TUITION EXPENSES LIKE BOOKS
AND TRANSPORTATION. AS YOU'VE
HEARD. TODAY I MEAN SENIOR
AGENDA MATERIALS WE HAVE A VERY
COMPLICATED SYSTEM. OF STATE
FINANCIAL AID. DUE TO
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS BASED ON
AGE. HOW LONG STUDENTS BEEN OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL AT THE TIME OF
THEIR APPLICATION FOR AID. AND
GRADE POINT AVERAGE FOR TOO
MANY OF OURMOST FINANCIALLY
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ARE LEFT
OUT OF THE CAL GRANT
ALTOGETHER. GIVEN THE DECREASED
ENROLLMENT SPEECH SEEN THIS
PAST FALL AND YOU DISCUSSED
EARLIER TODAY. AND THE
CONCERNING DROP IN APPLICATION
RATES FOR HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID.
THEY WERE REFERENCING A
PREVIOUS AGENDA ITEM. THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL THAT THE STUDENTS
ARE DEFERRING THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND- AND LATER TRIED
TO APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID. WE
MAY SEE EVEN LARGER NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS REFERRED TO THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE THEY'VE APPLIED MORE
THAN ONE YEAR AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. THE TAKEN WITH THE
EXACERBATING. STUDENTS ARE
FACING AND ADDRESSING THEIR
BASIC NEEDS MAKES OUR CONTINUED
FOCUS ON CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION ALL THE MORE
CRITICAL. OUR PROPOSAL TO
MODERNIZE THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS DIRECTLY YOU'RE
REFERRING TO AS A CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK SEEKS TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF
SIMPLIFYING AND STREAMLINING
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS.
REDUCING THE LEVELS OF DEBT
INCURRED BY STUDENTS. MAKING
FINANCIALLY MORE EQUITABLE BY
REMOVING ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
AND SETTING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AS THE BENCHMARK FOR
A PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS
LEVERAGING FEDERAL STATE AND
INSTITUTIONAL FUNDING SOURCES
TO MOST EFFECTIVELY SERVE OUR
STUDENTS. WE EQUITY FRAMEWORK
PROPOSES CONSOLIDATING THE
VARIOUS CAL GRANT PROGRAMS INTO
JUST YOU. A CAL GRANT TO THAT
SERVICE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND CAL GRANT FORD
THAT WOULD SERVE STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT THE OTHER SEGMENTS.
AS YOU. MAY KNOW THAT PROMISE
GRANT FORMERLY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS BE WAIVER ALREADY
PROVIDES TUITION D. COVERAGE
FOR OVER 40% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. HOWEVER
THERE'S VERY LITTLE AID
AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS. WE
PROPOSE A BIT CAL GRANT TO
PROVIDE ALL ELIGIBLE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH ZERO
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION.
THE MOST FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED IN OUR
EIGHT APPLICATIONS WITH A
STIPEND FOR NON TUITION COSTS.
THIS WOULD ELIMINATE EXISTING
BARRIERS BASED ON A STUDENT'S
AGE TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
I'M TRYING TO SERVE ADULT
LEARNERS WE WOULD ALSO
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR GPA
VERIFICATION. AS SECURING HIGH
SCHOOL TRANSCRIPT CAN BECOME A
BARRIER TO AID FOR. YOU NEED
PRO FOR COMMUTER COLLEGE WITH
LET US THAT AN APPLE. DEADLINE
OF SEPTEMBER SECOND. FOR THE
TELEPRINTER PROGRAM RELATIVE TO
THE OTHER INSTITUTIONS WHICH
WOULD HAVE A MARCH SECOND
DEADLINE. AND THIS WOULD
REFLECT THE ROLE OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND PROVIDING ACCESS
TO STUDENTS WITHOUT THE EARLIER
ADMISSIONS DEADLINES USED OTHER
SEGMENTS. ALL TOGETHER IN DOING
THIS WE COULD EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR CAL
GRANT TO AWARD BY MORE THAN A
125% MORE THAN DOUBLING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR
CAL GRANT. FROM HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS UNDER
CURRENT RULES TODAY TO TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
ONE OF YOUR APPLICATIONS. IN
THE MATERIALS TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE COMMITTEE YOU'LL SEE THAT
WE PLAYED OUT FUNDING OPTIONS
FOR CONSIDERATION AND HOW MUCH
AID WOULD BE BECOME AVAILABLE
TO STUDENTS. TODAY
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND CAL GRANT
FUNDS GO TO NEW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE RECIPIENTS EACH YEAR.
WITH THOSE FUNDS WE COULD OFFER
CALL ZERO DSC ELIGIBLE AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
A ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLAR CAL GRANT WORK.
THE CURRENT CAL GRANT BE ACCESS
AWARD FOR OUR- EYES ARE ONLY
NON TUITION ASSISTANCE AWARD.
PROVIDES ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX DOLLARS AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR THE COLLEGE
ACCESS TAX CREDIT PROGRAM. TO
MAINTAIN AN AWARD OF THAT SIZE
FOR THE CAL GRANT YOU WOULD
REQUIRE FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING. WE
WOULD ALSO SUGGESTED A GROWTH
INDEX OR OTHER METRICS BE
ESTABLISHED TO ENSURE THAT THE
CAL GRANT TO KEEP TRACK WITH
NON TUITION COSTS AND MAINTAINS
THE AWARDS PURCHASING POWER.
OVER TIME. OUR CAL GRANT FOR
PROGRAM WOULD SERVE STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT ALL OTHER
INSTITUTIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. STUDENTS WITH AN ESC
QUALIFYING THEM FOR A PELL
GRANT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE A CALTRAIN FOR. THE
CALGARY FOR WOULD MAITAIN THE
EXISTING TUITION AND FEES
COVERAGE FOR STUDENTS AT OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS
THE CURRENT AWARD LEVELS FOR
STUDENTS ENROLLED AT PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER WE WOULD
DO AWAY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
BASED ON AGE AND TIME OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL. THERE WOULD NO
LONGER BE A CAL GRANT BE ACCESS
AWARD SO INSTEAD WE WOULD
PROPOSE THAT INSTITUTIONS
UTILIZE INSTITUTIONAL AID. TO
PROVIDE ZERO ESE STUDENTS WITH
A STIPEND TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR
BASIC NEEDS. BY ELIMINATING NON
FINANCIAL ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
AND CONVERTING TO A TUITION AND
FEE- AWARD STRUCTURE WE CAN CUT
OFF FOR MORE THAN A FOR OVER
FORTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WITH THE CAL GRANT
FORWARD. RELATIVE TO TODAY'S
CAL GRANT REQUIREMENTS. ALL
JUST BRIEFLY NOTE THAT AT NO
POINT ON ARE WE PROPOSING TO
CUT OFF STUDENTS WERE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING AID TODAY WE WOULD-
PROPOSED TRANSITION AS WE
TRANSITION TO THE NEW CALTRAIN
EQUITY FRAMEWORK. THAT THE
STUDENTS BE ALLOWED TO
GRANDFATHER INTO THEIR EXISTING
PROGRAM UNTIL THEIR ELIGIBILITY
FOR AID SHOULD EXPIRE. THE COST
OPTIONS WE PRESENTED ALSO
REFLECT- THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATION LEVELS FOR
STUDENTS AT EACH SEGMENT AND WE
NOT SHOULD THE DOLLARS FROM ONE
SEGMENT TOWARDS ANOTHER. IN
LOOKING AT WHICH STUDENTS WOULD
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR THE CAL
GRANT THROUGH THIS EXPANSION
THE RECIPIENTS OF THE CAL RIGHT
TO WEAR CROWN GOT FORWARD WOULD
BE MORE LIKELY THAN TODAY'S
STUDENTS TO BE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE GOERS. ADULT LEARNERS
STUDENT PERRANCE. AND THEY
WOULD ALSO BE LOWER INCOME AND
MORE DIVERSE THAN TODAY'S
RECIPIENTS. THESE STUDENTS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM TODAY'S PROGRAM
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
THAT I'VE BEEN REFERENCING
ABOUT REMARKS. TO CONCLUDE I'D
LIKE TO OFFER YOU WITH WHAT THE
COMMISSION SEES AS THE KEY
OUTCOMES WE CAN ACHIEVE IN
ADOPTING A CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK. WE CAN STREAMLINE
THE CURRENT SEVEN CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS SO THEY'RE MORE EASILY
UNDERSTOOD BY STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AS WELL AS
COMMUNICATED BY COUNCILLORS. WE
CAN ALIGN THE ELIGIBILITY
STANDARDS FOR STATE AND FEDERAL
POLICY TO MAKE OUR SYSTEM MORE
COHESIVE AND COORDINATED. WE
CAN ELIMINATE THE ELIGIBILITY
BEAR YOUR STATE THAT ARE
DISCONNECTED FROM QUESTIONS OF
FINANCE AND IN DOING SO WE CAN
TARGET STATE RESOURCES FOR MOST
FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. MORE TANGIBLY CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK WOULD
YIELD OVER ONE HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN THOUSAND MORE. ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS THAN TODAY SYSTEM IN
ONE YEAR OF APPLICATIONS AND
CALIFORNIA COULD BETTER
LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING BY
CONVERTING TO TUITION AND FEES
AWARDS IN THE CAL GRANT FOR
PROGRAM. WITH FORTY THOUSAND
MORE TUITION VIEW WARDS THERE
WOULD BE FORTY THOUSAND MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAT WOULD
RECEIVE A TEN OF FUNDED BENEFIT
AND BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
CALFRESH FEDERALLY FUNDED
BENEFITS. THIRTY HIGHER NUMBERS%
OF STUDENTS PARENTS ADULT
LEARNERS IN CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT APPLICATION FILERS ELIGIBLE
FOR AID. AND CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK MAKES OUR CAL GRANT
SYSTEM MORE INCLUSIVE
PARTICULARLY FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO STUDENTS.
SO I I'D LIKE TO INCLUDING HERE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY I'M I KNOW
WE'VE SHARED A LOT IN THE
MATERIALS AND- TRY TO COVER A
LOT OF BROWN IN THESE REMARKS
BRIEF REMARKS TODAY. SO WE
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS AND I'M
ALSO JOINED BYMY COLLEAGUE
PATRICK PERRY ART DIRECTOR DATA
ANALYSIS AND RESEARCH SHOULD
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE DATA OR THE MODELING THAT'S
BEEN INCLUDED IN YOUR AGENDA
MATERIALS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I HAVE A QUESTION
BUT BEFORE I ASK IT- I'M GOING
TO HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THIS
AND SO. WHOEVER THINKS THEY
MIGHT HAVE THIS IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE%
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SHOULD ON
MUTE THEMSELVES AND THEN ALL
ASK THEM AFTER. ASKING MISTER
BURNER. THAN. MISTER BURNER
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT YOU'VE GOT
LOT OF FOR. OUT IN YOUR- IN OUR
LIKE TO STAY BACK A LITTLE. AND
JUST ARE MORE LOW PUT IT INTO
CON. BECAUSE OF ONE THING
SOUNDED TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE.
WHICH IS THAT WE WOULD- DEAL
WITH SOME OF THE PROBLEMS AND
THERE WOULD BE NO ADDITIONAL
COST. TO DEAL WITH THE PROBLEMS
AND HAVE MORE PEOPLE AND I
THINK THERE'S A CONTINUE ON
HERE ON THIS ISSUE. IT IS SORT
OF TRYING TO FIX THE BARRIERS
THAT ARE IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
AND THEN IT'S TRYING TO AT SOME
POINT EXPAND TO MORE WRAPAROUND
TO REFORM. THAT INCLUDES THINGS
THAT ARE JUST FEES BUT BOXER
HOUSING FOR OTHER ISSUES. AND I
JUST WONDERED WHAT IS THE
CONTINUE ON HERE WHAT YOU'RE
RECOMMENDING OR WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. AND THE HARD
QUESTION IT'S LIKE WHAT'S THE
COST. IN GENERAL AND- WHERE
WOULD YOU LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDS WE DON'T GET AND WHERE
WOULD IT. BE A GREATER COST TO
THE STATE. A VERY GOOD QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR POINTS
ARE VERY WELL TAKEN- WE DO WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION BELIEVE THAT IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE- BOTH SIMPLIFY
AND STREAMLINE FINANCIALLY. AS
WELL AS EXPAND THE SUPPORT THAT
WE CAN MAKE AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. I IS YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS NOTED I'M
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR SEVERAL
YEARS TO- STUDY HOW WE COULD
BETTER STRUCTURE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
TODAY'S STUDENTS- THOSE EFFORTS
HAD YIELDED A REPORT THAT WAS
ISSUED IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
JUST BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN AT.
AND THAT PROPOSAL WAS TABLED
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE YEAR.
OVER THE SUMMER OUR LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS ASKED THAT WE LOOK AT
HOW WE COULD MODEL THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATION LEVELS AS THEY
STOOD IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. TO REFLECT THE PROPOSAL
THAT WAS ISSUED IN MARCH. BUT
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS. AN
URGENCY TO NOT ONLY SIMPLIFYING
THE SYSTEM AND REMOVING THE
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS BUT
BRINGING TO BEAR GREATER
RESOURCES THAT WE CAN USE TO
HELP SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS IN COVERING THOSE
BASIC NEEDS AND NON TUITION
COSTS. THAT YOU JUST
REFERENCED. ONE OPPORTUNITY
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND IT
SPEAKS TO THE QUESTION YOU
POSED AROUND THE FEDERAL
RESOURCES. IS AROUND THE NATURE
OF OUR- CAL GRANT PROGRAMS-
TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY
FAMILIES. FUNDING AND THE
CALFRESH PROGRAM- AS PART OF
THE- PROCESS FOR AWARDING US.
WHO RECEIVED A TUITION AND FEE
AWARD- FOR THE CALGARY PROGRAM
CURRENTLY WE ALSO NOTIFIED THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY'VE RECEIVED
UP. BENEFIT THAT'S BEEN FUNDED
IN PART BY A TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY FAMILIES
FUNDING AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECEIVES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THERE'S AN
EXISTING RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE
FOR THE FEDERAL SNAP PROGRAM OR
FOOD STAMPS THAT PREVENT MANY
STUDENTS WITH- OFTEN VERY DIRE
FINANCIAL NEED WHAT WILL MR
BURDEN OR LET ME PUT A FINER
POINT ON IT. CAN YOU DO THE
REFORMS. TO JUST ELIMINATE THE
BARRIERS. AND ADD MORE PEOPLE
BY ELIMINATING THE BARRIERS.
AND NOT CHANGING SORT OF THE
GRANT SYSTEM. CAN YOU DO THAT
WITH AN EXISTING FUNDS. WE'VE
LAID OUT IN OUR MATERIALS THAT
WE PROVIDED HE- RAMIFICATIONS
FOR MOVING TOWARDS THIS CAL
GRANT YOU WIN FOR SYSTEM WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT I WENT IN AND IS
IT THE IF YOU MOVE TOWARD IT
WITH EXISTING RESOURCES YOU CAN
COVER LESS PEOPLE. FOR YOU CAN
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO USE THE
EXISTING RESOURCES AND LOWER
THE BARRIERS AND COVER MORE
PEOPLE AND MAKE IT ALL WORK
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES. YES
MISTER JEFFREY PLAYED OUT BE
OPTION AND IN THE- RESOURCES
ARE JUST NOT EVERYBODY HAS
BENEFIT OF YOUR STAFF REPORTER
WHAT YOU'VE LAID OUT THERE JUST
LISTENING AND I'M TRYING TO GET
YOU TO TELL THEM WHAT THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IS.
MISTER CHAIR NO IT'S NO PROBLEM
I'M JUST GOING TO KEEP AT IT
TILL I GET THERE. WE WANT
EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND THAT I'M
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE
WITH THIS PROPOSAL SO AND USING
THE EXISTING FUNDS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATED TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. WE COULD
EXPAND THAT BASE OF STUDENTS- I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY AND GETS
ITS WATER EIGHTY THOUSAND.
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS PROBLEM-
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TODAY. BUT THE RAMIFICATIONS
THERE IS THAT THERE WILL BE A
SMALLER AWARD THAT WE WOULD
OFFER TO STUDENTS IT WOULD BE
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR WARD. RATHER THAN THE
CURRENT ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX DOLLARS OR
AND I WAS THERE WAS ONE I WAS I
WANT TO GET TO THE SECOND CALL
BACK TO THE SECOND QUESTION
BUT- WHEN I WAS BUDGET CHAIR.
IN THE ASSEMBLY A DECADE AGO. I
WAS THE ARCHITECT OF A FEE ROLL
BACK FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
IT ALWAYS MAY DELAY- CRAZY
BECAUSE THE L. A- WANTED CHEESE
TO GO UP AND HAVE THE PELL
GRANT BE THE THING THAT. THAT
REALLY BENEFITED AND THOUGHT
THE FEE ROLLBACK WAS NEEDLESS
AND WOULD GO BACK AND FORTH
WITH THE OHIO. IS THAT STILL IN
PLAY WITH REGARD TO LEVERAGING
FEDERAL GRANTS AND HAVING THE
FEDERAL GRANTS PAY MORE FEES IF
WE RAISE THE FEES FOR PEOPLE
THAT. ARE IN THAT INCOME
CATEGORY. BUT IN THE- PROPOSAL
WE PUT FORTH WE WOULD
ENVISIONED THE PROMISE GRANT
WOULD TO COVERAGE AND- HELLO
WOULD BE UP AT THE END
GENEALOGY OF ACRONYMS THE
PROMISE GRANT IS THE SUCCESSOR
TO THE BALL GRUYTER BRYANT.
OKAY JUST FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOLLOWING AT HOME. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY- MISTER CHAIR SO THE
PROMISE GRANT FORMERLY THE FEE
WAIVER WOULD CONTINUE TO COVER
TUITION AND FEES FOR- THAT
POPULATION. TWO WOULD THEN BE
LATER TO TALK BACK TO HELP
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH THEIR NON
TUITION COSTS AND WITH THEIR
BASIC NEEDS NOW TO GO TO THE
SECOND QUESTION. IF YOU WERE TO
FOLLOW THE REFORM. THAT RELY
WRAPS AROUND OTHER THINGS SO
THAT IT'S NOT JUST FEES BUT YOU
START TO GET TO HOUSING OR
BOOKS OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY WHERE PEOPLE RACK UP
THE DEBT. BOMB THAT WHERE IF
YOU WANT TO THAT. IS EITHER
SUBSTANTIAL. THERE'S NO WAY YOU
COULD HAVE THOSE THINGS AND
REDUCE THE GRANT SO IT'S REALLY
YOU'RE ADDING ACOSTA CHIU HOPE
WILL. BE COVERED FROM SOMEWHERE
RIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE COULD
AS A AS I A NOTE WE CAN TO THAT
FIFTY NO DOLLARS AND SPREAD
ACROSS ADDITION STUDENTS. THAT
WOULD YIELD- LOWER AWARDED THAT
IN THE CURRENT PROGRAM OUR WE
DO BELIEVE THAT WITH THAT
TARGETED INVESTMENT. THE FORTY
SIX MILLION THAT IDENTIFIED AN
ONGOING RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
MAINTAIN THE AWARD AMOUNT WE
CAN GO EVEN FURTHER IN OUR
EFFORTS TO SERVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO WE KNOW AS
AS USUAL HERE TO REALLY. WHAT
YOUR DESCRIBING IS A PARTIALLY
SELF DEFEATING SITUATION WHERE
YOU EXPAND THE GRANTS TO COVER
OTHER COSTS FOR THERE'S NO DEBT
WHICH OF TO LOWER THE AMOUNT OF
THE DEBT TO EXPAND THE GRANTS
TO. LOWER THE AMOUNT OF THE
GRANT TO EXPAND GRANTS TO
PEOPLE THAT'S SORT OF THE
PREMISE RIGHT. I MEAN WITHOUT A-
REVENUE GEN. OR REVENUE YOU
COULD CHANGE WORLD BUT THAT'S
THE- THAT'S THE DYNAMIC CORRECT.
AT YES MR JERRY NOW THE REQUEST
WE RECEIVE FROM OUR LOW WITH TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
BEAT COULD BE A WITHIN THE FOR
WHAT AND THEN TO IDENTIFY IT IS
RESOURCE WOULD BE NO TO ADD OR
YOUR ORDER MAIL OR GROW THAT
AWARD AMOUNTS TO GO EVEN
GREATER. OF KNOWLEDGE AND COSTS
THANK YOU AND THEN THE REYES I
ASK FOR AND- BREANNA BURNS HAS
MAGICALLY APPEARED HERE AT THE
TOP OF THE SCREEN OR STAFF IF
YOU'D- ON ANY POSITION FINANCER
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS. BOND
GRANT REFORM. SORRY BRIANNA
FRIENDS DIFFERENT FINANCE YOU
FOR YOUR- I THIS POINT WE DO
NOT HAVE. A FORMAL POSITION TO
RECOMMEND. ON THIS TO EIGHT
STRUCTURE. WE ARE STILL. AND
LOOKING- OF THE IN THE CASE
THAT AND MY CALL WAS DIFFERENT-
HAS JUST IDENTIFIED. SO WE'RE
STILL IN THE AND NOW. BY AT
THIS TIME. CAN WELL IT WILL.
ARM FULLY OF WHAT GOVERNOR'S
DURING CAMPAIGN SO YOU LIKE IF.
THE CONDO DOESN'T TANK YOU
PREVIOUS TO HELP WITH THE SO-
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD AND I KNOW.
THAT. CENTER OCHO BOCA JOINED
AND- MISSED ASKING A AND ITEMS.
B. SHE WAS A ANOTHER CA HEARING
BUT IT TURNS THAT COULD. MIGHT
RELATE TO THIS AND I THINK BACK.
WHAT HAVE GONE TO BERMAN. SO
I'M GONNA RECOGNIZE ROACH BOGUE
LETTER ASPECT. A SEE IF IT. TO
WORK THIS. GOOD MORNING AND I
POWER. FOR MISSING THE FIRST OF
THE COMMITTEE. I WAS IN A-
ANOTHER COMMITTEE MEETING
SCHEDULE JUST SLIGHTLY BEFORE
TIME- I DO HAVE. A WITH TO-
THIS CAL GRANT WITH. AND FAST
SO. PUBLIC PROCESS IS MY- THAT
WE CURRENTLY- IN THE PAST YEARS
LEFT OVER. I FIRED CORRECTLY
FIVE HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS
AT THE TABLE BECAUSE OF STILL
NOT A FOR FASTER. AND IN. IN
CONTEXT OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE FOR- DARIUS
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND GOING
INTO- HIGHER EDUCATION I'M KIND
OF WONDERING IF. ONE DO WE KNOW
WHY THE FASTER APPLICATION
PROCESS HAS NOT BEEN A- A
REQUISITE FOR ALL OF OUR
SENIORS- GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL
MOVING FORWARD WHY THEY HAVEN'T
THAT ONE HASN'T BEEN A
REQUISITE FOR MOST OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND IF THE
STUDENTS WERE REQUIRED TO APPLY
FOR THE FASTA APPLICATION WOULD
THEY BE ABLE TO- MEET MEANT
MUCH OF THE NEEDS THAT WE
CURRENTLY ARE ADDRESSING RIGHT
NOW WITH ALL OF THE REFORMS AND
WITHIN THAT PROCESS. WITH THE
CAL GRANT BE EFFECTED BY I'M
NOT AFFECTED BY GUESTS INCLUDED
WITHIN THAT THOSE MONIES. THANK
YOU GREAT QUESTION SENATOR.
TAKE THEM UP IN PART AND
HOPEFULLY I CAN ALL OF COULD BE
A QUICK THAT YOU HAD- DID FUNDS
THAT YOU. THAT ARE BEING LET ON
THE TWO LIKE STUDENTS WHO APPLY
FOR FINANCIAL AID WOULD INCLUDE
STATE AND FEDERAL AID SOURCES
AND THE SAME APPLICATIONS THAT
WE USE FOR THE PAST- OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT. PROVIDES
STUDENTS WITH ELIGIBILITY FOR
FEDERAL AID AND FOR STATE SO IN
HELP BRING MORE STUDENTS
COMPLETE. THOSE APPLICATIONS WE
HELP THEM NOT ONLY ACCESS THE
STATE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS BUT
ALSO THAT FEDERAL PELL GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WE REFERENCED
EARLIER- I WOULD. HAVE TO
PROBABLY DEFERRED OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR- YOU KNOW WHY DON'T
KNOW WHY THAT THE REQUIREMENT
WAS IN PLACE PREVIOUSLY I KNOW
THAT THIS HAS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
ADOPTED IN OTHER STATES I
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
ALSO. IMPLEMENTED A SIMILAR
REQUIREMENT TO HELP MORE OF
THEIR STUDENTS COMPLETE AND
THAT THAT'S BEEN A VERY
SUCCESSFUL UNDERTAKING- BUT-
RE. COLLEAGUES THAT FINANCE
MAY HAVE FURTHER INSIGHT INTO
THE- TIMING OF THE PROPOSAL.
FINANCED WITH LIKE TO THAT.
SORRY BRIANNA FRIEND DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND REGIONAL I CAN'T ON
YOU KNOW WHY IT BEEN A TODAY-
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS FOR IS
TRULY FOR ON A AND DEBT ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN BY TO OUR TEAM WE
UNDER. THAT THEY IS MONEY LEFT
ON THE TEAM AND WE THAT THAT
PROPOSAL WE HAVE CURRENTLY INTO
BUILDING ISN'T APPROACH- TO YOU
KNOW THE FEELING. OF AFTER
REQUIRE SO YEAH I CAN SPEAK TO
THE WHY INCLUDED IN THIS BY
THAT CAN SPEAK TO WHITE HOUSE
BEEN INCLUDE TO DATE. THAT AT
QUESTIONS WANNA FALL UP WITH.
BUDGET WANNA MAKE SURE I UNDER.
CORRECT SO THESE MAY. THAT ARE.
LEFT AT THE TABLE. WOULD WE
ADDITIONAL. AND TOWARDS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- AND ARCEUS
USER UC'S WOULD WE NEED THAT
ADDITIONAL MONEY. IF THESE IF
THESE MONIES FROM THE FIVE
SEVEN CAL AB FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FROM CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERAL FUNDS WOULD THEY MEET
THOSE NEEDS ARE DOING IS THAT
IN ADDITION TO. UTILIZING ARE
MAXIMIZING THE USE OF THESE
FUNDS. THROUGH THE FASTER
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SENATOR. IF
THERE SHOULD BE AN INCREASE IN
THE APPLICATION RATES- FOR
STUDENTS WHICH WE WOULD
ENVISION UNDER THIS PROPOSALOF
COURSE THERE WOULD BE
RAMIFICATIONS ON OUR-
POTENTIALLY ON OUR COST
ESTIMATES FOR THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS BECAUSE MORE STUDENTS
WOULD BE APPLYING UNDER THE
HIGH SCHOOL ENTITLEMENT THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TODAY FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE APPLYING
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION. THE IMPACT
THERE IS HARD TO ASSESS RIGHT
NOW WE'RE STILL- UNDERTAKING
THOSE EFFORTS AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION- BECAUSE THERE
HAS BEEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE AND THE APPLICATION
RATES FOR HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
THIS YEAR VERY LIKELY DUE TO
THE COLD NINETEEN PANDEMIC SO
IN THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE WE
WOULD HAVE A FEW COUNTERVAILING
FACTORS AS WE TRY TO. DEVELOP A
COST ESTIMATE FOR- CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS- HOLDING IN MIND THE
POTENTIAL FOR THIS REQUIREMENT-
BE DEDUCTED IN THE STATE BUDGET
ACT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
WELCOME YOUR QUESTION CENTER
REMAINED GERMANY QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE. THEN WELCOME OUR
CONCERN OF THE ITEM SO
SUBSTANTIVELY WE WILL NOW MOVES
TO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO COMMENT- ON
ANY ITEM THAT WAS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY TO REMIND EVERYBODY. THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE
SEVEN I'LL BE LIMITING
EVERYBODY TO ONE. MINUTE
CANASTA TERROR THE GOOD DECORUM
ON THIS BUT FIRST I'M GOING TO
GO TO THE TWO MEETING ROOMS AND
ASKED FOR ANY WITNESSES OR
THERE. IS THERE ANY WITNESSED
IT WISHES TO SPEAK THAT IS IN
THIS COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. SEEING NONE AWLAD IF
THERE A WHAT- HE'S IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THAT WISHES TO THE
COMMITTEE. SAYING NO ONE VENN
MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS AND IF YOU WOULD-
OUR QUEUE UP CALLERS INTO WERE
READY TO HEAR FROM THEM. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY SIMPLY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS GOING
TO PULL YOU OFF LINE REAL QUICK
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACKING QUEUE. SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AT FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING THIS DANIELLE ONE
DRUG WITH. NOW WE WANT TO X.
OUR- SUPPORT FOR THE- BUDGET.
TO PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL CAL
GRANT TO WORK FOR STUDENT
CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY IN FOSTER
CARE. EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
THE STUDENTS FACE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT IMPACTED THEIR
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS. INCLUDING
THE EFFECTS OF THE TRAUMA OF
ABUSE AND NEGLECT. AND BEING
REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
EXPERIENCING MULTIPLE PLACEMENT
CHANGES IN SCHOOL TRANSFERS AND
A LACK OF FAMILY SUPPORT TO
HELP THEM TRANSITION. AND
PERSISTENT POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. HE CHALLENGES THE
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND THE PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
IS CRITICAL FOR HELPING FOSTER
YOUTH DAY IN SCHOOL AND BE
SUCCESSFUL DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND BEYOND. IN ADDITION
CHILDREN NOW SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT AWARDS AVAILABLE EACH
YEAR. TO FIFTY THOUSAND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATE NEXT. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING- MY
NAME IS MARINO VALLEY FONG AND
I'M THE PROGRAM COORDINATOR OF
CALLERS WHICH IS TO OTHERS YES
GUARDIAN COLOR FROM. LIKE OR
FUNDING INCLUDE AND GOVERNOR
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS YOU
WITH THE CAL GRANT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING THE- WITH COLLEGE
STUDENTS A FOSTER BACK FOR SOME
YEARS AND HAVE TO HUNDREDS OF
DURING THE TIME BUT MY NAME
BURDEN IS THE BIG OCT TO GET
ATTAIN THEIR BATCH TO SO THIS
FINANCIALLY THANK WITH OVERALL
THAT COMES WITH MY CHALLENGE.
OF THE RESULT OF FAMILIES OF
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE DUE TO
CHILD TRAUMA THIS FINANCIALLY
INCREASE BUT ALSO REDUCE LONGER
AND ALLOW STUDENTS TO WORK LESS
HOURS OR NOT NOT AT ALL RATHER
THAN WORKING UP TIME JOB WHILE
A FULL TIME TO. ONLY 4% OF ALL
YOU A ABOUT DEGREE SO THIS
WOULD IN WOULD CERTAINLY HELP
TO ALL OF THAT NUMBER THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MODERATOR NECK CALL. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY TWO ARE ALL. HELLO
MY NAME IS BIANCA AND I HAVEN'T
OF WERE WITH FOSTER YOUTH THAT
SHE GO STATE PART OF MY AND
INTERN WITH COLLARS PROGRAM. I
RECOGNIZE STUDENTS NEED FOR
DAYS IN AS MANY CONTINUE
STRUGGLE MEETING THEIR BASIC
NEEDS AS AND HOW. NEEDS EARN
ADDITIONAL FOR BATES ME DOES
TAKE AWAY AND THEY BEING ON
COURSE. THIS IS A DIFFERENT
COMPARED TO THE NON BY CARE.
AND THE CAN EASILY LEAD TO.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT I
AM STEPHANIE ARTWORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE TO CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE SERVING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN THE
CHILD WELFARE INFORMATION
SYSTEM I. WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
INCREASE IN THE CAL GRANT
ACCESS AWARD FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CARE LAYERED IN
MEMBERS LAURA BARBECUE THAT
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS YOUR HIGHER
EDUCATION RESEARCH AND POLICY
ORGANIZATION THAT LEAD
CALIFORNIANS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY AND DIVERSE
COALITION UNITED IN
STRENGTHENING STATE NEED BASED
FINANCIAL AID. WE URGE OUR
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT TO
FIFTY THOUSAND THANK YOUR
PREVIOUS INVESTMENTS OLDER
STUDENTS ARE THE PROCEEDING AND
GRANT HAVE IMPROVED FROM JUST
ONE SEVENTEEN A FEW YEARS AGO
TO ONE EIGHT TODAY HOWEVER
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS STILL GOING
OUT THE CAL GRANT THEY NEED NOW
TO BE SUCCESSFUL I NEED
ADDITIONAL AWARDS WOULD ENSURE
THOUSANDS MORE HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO THRIVE
TODAY. WE ALSO URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE STUDENT ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID FOR TOTAL COLLEGE
COSTS INCLUDING REQUIRING LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES SUPPORT HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETION OF
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
STRENGTHENING CAL GRANT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND BROADER
FINANCIAL AID REFORM THAT
ADDRESSES THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES
INCLUDING THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
A ROBUST ACCESS AWARD FOR NON
TUITION COSTS THE GROWTH
MEANINGFULLY OVER TIME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. SIX WE WILL FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE CALL. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS DEBBIE RASHER I'M A JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YEARS I'M
ALSO HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AROUND EXPANDING THE CAL GRANT
FOR FOSTER YOUTH I'LL JUST
POINT OUT THAT FOSTER YOUTH
COLLEGE COMPLETION LAG
SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND THOSE NOT
ONLY OF THE GENERAL STUDENT
POPULATION BUT ALSO THAT OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. ONE STUDY TO
FOUR UNIVERSITIES FOUND THAT
JUST 40% OF FOSTER GRADUATED
COMPARED 274% A LOW INCOME
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL AID IS A
PROVEN METHOD HOWEVER CHANGING
THESE NUMBERS ALSO YOU TO
RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN AID ARE
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
PERSIST. PLUS YOU DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO FAMILY SUPPORT TO
MANY OTHER STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO IN FACT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS REMOVED THE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR HOME DUE TO
SEVERE ABUSE OR NEGLECT IT HAS
TAKEN ON THE ROLE OF PARENTS
FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE. TO INCLUDE THE
FUNDS IN THE STATE BUDGET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
SENATOR BURTON CAN- COMMITTEES
REGARDS. BUT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT CUTTING. NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SEVEN.
MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSHAN EVAN
AND I WOULD PROJECTED WITHOUT
YOUR CARE SYSTEM I MEAN YOU
THOUGHT JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
YOU I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE CARE FORM
OF YOU SUB IN THE COVERING
AWARDS. OF THE TRIAL IN FOSTER
CARE HOW TO UNDERGO CERTAIN BUT
NO SHOW SHOULD EVER TO. I COULD
UNDER SEE HOW WATER PUT ME
THROUGH MY COLLEGE AND I KNOW
THE BACK WITH I WOULD HAVE. IT
NOT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS BASIC NECESSITIES
ARE JOBS THINGS LIKE FOOD WOULD
HAVE IMPACT MY COLLEGE EDUCATED
DRAMATIC. MANY COLLEGES THROUGH
CALIFORNIA HAVE WITH FOR YOUTH
ARE WILLING HELP TO SUPPORT THE.
NAVIGATING. OPEN TO THRIVE NOT
JUST SURVIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU WERE ONE
MINUTE ON THE BOTTOM. A
MODERATE JUST COLOR. THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE LADY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE I'M HAPPY TO EDUCATION
TRUST WISE. BE HAVING COLLISION
OF YOUR DEGREE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING CALCULATION OF
COMMERCE NOTED WHAT THE
FOUNDATION IS AMERICANS DASHING
TO HOLD CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS.
CONSTRAINING STRONG SUPPORT IN
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA THAT
COMPLETION. PROPOSAL
CALIFORNIANS BEHIND ATTACK
INDIANA LOUISIANA AND ILLINOIS.
PASSED A SIMILAR FINDING
COMPLETION. NOT ONLY BECAUSE
YOU CAN USE OF THE ISSUE ALSO
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ACTIVE ON
POLICY. TO HELP BUILD FUTURE
WORKFORCE. IN THE LAST TWO. NOT
MADE BY TWENTY YOU KNOW DOLLARS
BE LEFT THE TABLE AND STATE AND
FEDERAL AID. BECAUSE NEARLY
HALF A MILLION HIGH STUDENTS TO
BE COME YOUR APPLICATION. THIS
IS GOING TO AN NEW PROCESSOR.
THAT IS AVAILABLE ALLEGATIONS
THAT NOW. WHETHER IT PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T BE LAST MILE POLICY
WHO SHOULD WHICH- THE GOOD OF
THE BED ON CALIFORNIA. NUMEROUS
PROBE SERVICES INITIATIVES
STATE. WERE IN TWO BY AID-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HAPPENED
TO COME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NO CALL. THANK YOU
LINES SO PLEASE CALL. HI GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE THIS IS SAMMY
MOLINA FOR ME HOLD. AND WE'RE
CALLING IN SICK OF A OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S TO ENSURE THAT I
SENIOR COMPLETE YOU'VE GOT.
AND- CAL DREAMIN I. THANK YOU.
WHY FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD. WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. HELLO YES
YOUR HONOR WELCOME TO OUR
COMMITTEE. HELLO. BUILDING
ALONG WE WILL ALIGN SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHARLIE CAN BE VERY
I'M THE PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR
UC BERKELEY'S CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS
BRICKLEY HOPE SCHOLARS. I
GREATLY EXPRESSED SUPPORT THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT FORMER CLASS
YOU WILL CAL GRANT WARD. MANY
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS YOU
STUDENT EXPERIENCE HOUSING
INSECURITY EXPOSURE TO TRAUMA
AND I'M GLAD THE FAMILY SUPPORT
AND MENTORSHIP OUR STUDENTS TO
PERSEVERE THROUGH SOME ENGAGED
TO MEET OPTICAL THAT GENERAL
STUDENT POP TO COULD NOT HAVE
ONE DOOR THE PANDEMIC IN THE
DOCK. THESE JOHN EVEN. THIS
GRANT WITH INSPIRED CONSISTENT
IN UNDER HOW IN THE SUMMER AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE. TO HELP
CALL MEDICAL DENTAL AND FEDERAL
SERVICE PERHAPS ACTIVE CHILD IS
GRANTED FOR MORE APPROACH TO
TURN CURRENT FORM YOU IN HIGHER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR OF MODERN NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU THANKS THREE CALL.
HELLO MY NAME'S ARE THANK YOU
NEAR ARE YOU BURKE I'M A FAR
FAR NEW FROM CONTRACT ACCOUNT
AND THEIR TAX CUT THEIR SUPPORT
OF THE FUNDING INCLUDING IN THE
GOVERNOR THANK YOU BECAUSE OF
THE PRICE FORM FOX NEWS THE
SETTLEMENT- CAL. I LOOK FORWARD
THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW HAVE
WITH THE TWICE FROM BUT YEAH
YOU CAN BILL THANK LOCAL BUT
CHAO INTERVIEWS HOW DOES THAT
SHOW EVENT BE FINE MY PART IN.
MAKING RIGHT OR NOT ONLY THAT
KEEP THEM YOUR **** OF THE
SUMMER WINTER BREAK YOU ALL OF
A MY COULD EVER THAT COVER I AM
DISTRACTED MY CAN NEXT TO
STRETCH ACTUALLY NEED WITH OUR
OWN DOUBLE. I'M GOING TO
TRUCKED FROM MAGGIE COOLEY AND
INVOLVED CAMPUS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERN NEXT CALLER. FONG WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WITH SUPPLEMENTAL
CAL GRANT AWARD. WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE VARIETY OF BARRIERS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION OUTSIDE OF
TUITION COSTS. FOR INTENT
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY THAN THEIR
PEERS TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS. HOUSING
INSTABILITY INCLUDING SECURITY.
THEY'RE ALSO LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE FAMILY OR OTHER ADULT
RESOURCES TO HELP THEM
FINANCIALLY. PROVIDING SUPPORT
FOR NON TUITION COSTS WILL HELP
WHAT YOU'VE OVERCOME THESE
BARRIERS AND PUT THEM ON A PATH
TOWARD COLLEGE GRADUATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS BRIDGET QUEST AND
I'M HOPING AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA CRUZ AND I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YEARS I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CAL GRANT A WAR. DURING MY TIME
AS A STUDENT YOU SEE AT THE
I'VE FACED MANY HOUSING
INCLUDING SECURITY ITS BUDGET
TIME THAT LEFT ME HOMELESS
STARVING. OTHER STUDENTS THAT
THEY SUCH INSECURITIES ARE
OFTEN ABLE TO REACH OUT TO
THEIR FAMILIES FOR ASSISTANCE.
WITH THE BUTTON ABOUT THE
CHARACTERS THEM RARELY HAVE
THAT LUXURY PERSONALLY I'VE HAD
TO DROP OUT OF COLLEGE TWICE.
TO MY INABILITY TO PAY HOUSING
COSTS. WHICH IS EXTENDED THE
LENGTH OF ACQUIRING MY DEGREE
FROM TWO YEAR TO TEN. WHILE
LABOR DAY MY COLLEGE PROCEEDS
TO INSTRUCT OF THE POSSIBILITY
OF REPEATED HOMELESSNESS IS A
VERY REAL OPTICAL MAKE DADDY. I
BELIEVE THAT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CAL GRANT AWARDS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS
BOON AND PROVIDING. SUPPORT TO
THOSE OF US THAT DON'T HAVE A
FAMILY UNIT CAROLINA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IT'S REALLY
MEANINGFUL WE APPRECIATE IT.
MODERATOR MEXICO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN WE WILL GO
LINES TO TWO GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR A WHILE ME TO
SPEAK TODAY. I'M A FORMER COST
YOU COULD WELL IN THE CAR
SENIOR ACCOUNT IN YOUR BILL.
AND ALL LIKE TO SUPPORT FUNDING.
R. GOVERNOR BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROVIDE COLONEL QUALIFIES YOU
FOR METAL CAL THAT AWARDS SH
BECAUSE LAST ARE FINANCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED THE MOST WORK FOR
CARMEN OFTENTIMES THE MOST WHAT
MULTIPLE JOBS. THE PORT. GOING
TO COLLEGE MANY CASES WATER
BIBLE. ARTS BECAUSE OF AN
INJURY VERY AND ARE NOT WE
DON'T HAVE FAMILY OR PARENTS TO
TAKE ABOUT. I DON'T MEAN ANY
MONEY JUST FOR TUITION AND
BOOKS WE NEED CONCLUDES THAT
WENT INTERNET WE NEED IT TO
SURVIVE. THE FUNDING ADDITIONAL.
OF THE BOSTON CAN SPEAK TO GET
A COLLEGE. AND CREATE A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEMSELVES. FINDING A
WHOLE BEGIN TO BREAK DOWN THE
COST BOTH FINANCIAL. AND
PROFESSIONAL CAREERS THANK YOU
BASED IN THEIR EFFORTS TO THE
CONSEQUENCE ADULTS WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL FOR. SO THOUSAND
PER YEAR IN CALGARY ON THE
FOOTBALL SHOES THANK YOU FOR A
LONG EXPECTED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SPEAKING- MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. FINE FIFTY. YOUR
LINE IS A- BY GETTING MY NAME
IS GREEN FINE WITH BOTH ANGELES
MISSION COLLEGE AND I'VE WORKED
WITH FOSTER STUDENTS FOR OVER
TWO YEARS. I WOULD LIKE EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNMENT BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH DIDN'T WITH A
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT AWARD
UNLIKE YOUR OWN BIRTH CHILDREN
FOSTER YOU HAVE DO NOT HAVE
THEIR BIRTH PARENTS OR FAMILY
SUPPORT IN PLACE TO DO THE
BLACK THE BLACK OF SUPPORT YOU
WHEN THEY ARE IN CRISIS. THE
RELY ON THEMSELVES AND MOVE
FORWARD WHICH LEADS TO MOTIONS
HAVING TO DROP THEIR COLLEGE
CLASSES TO GET A MINIMUM WAGE
JOB TO PAY FOR HOUSING BILLS
EXCEPT RAP WHICH IS INTENDED
THEIR ABILITY TO FURTHER
CONTINUE WITH THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION GET A GOOD DEGREE
WHICH LEADS TO THE INABILITY TO
CONSTRUCT THE SOCIO ECONOMIC
LADDER AND FIFTEEN EMPLOYMENT.
I HAD SEEN SITUATION FIRSTHAND
ON MANY OCCASIONS I WORK WITH
MANY FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS AND HAVE AT
TO DROP OUT OF COLLEGE HIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW STUDENTS THE
ABILITY TO STAY IN THEIR
COLLEGE BY PROVIDING BOX
STUDENTS WITH THE NECESSARY
MONETARY SUPPORT MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS. WHICH WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO GET A DEGREE TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF SOCIETY CAN
BETTER JOBS AND REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AND JOBLESSNESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR MODERATOR MEXICO. ONE SIXTY
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MR
CHAIRMAN I AM CARO THE CAL
LIBRARIES. I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THE STATE
LIBRARY ITEMS PROPOSED FOR
FUNDING BY THE GOVERNOR ON YOUR
AGENDA INCLUDING THE PHOENIX
FEES YOU HAVE RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM ME AND MY DILLON
INDICATING FEELINGS ADDITIONAL
REQUEST FOR TP FUNDING FOR SAY
FREE OPENING AND RESTORATION OF
A CUT MADE IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET TO THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY SERVICES ACT. BUT THE
ISSUE THAT IS OF IMMEDIATE
CONCERN IS THE NEED TO
ACCELERATE THE EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
THE LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
PROGRAM. INTO AN EARLY ACTION
BUDGET TRAILER BILL SO THAT
CHILDREN CAN RECEIVE MEALS AT
THE LIBRARY IN THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CLA SUPPORTS
THE STATE LIBRARIANS EFFORT AND
WE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR POSITIVE COMMENTS WITHOUT
EARLY ACTION FIFTEEN LIBRARY
SITES IN MONTEREY COUNTY AND
SITES IN TUSTIN COSTA MESA
HAMILTON SAMPOERNA DINO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO SERVE CHILDREN IN
NEED OF LUNCH OF THE SUMMER.
FOR SOME CHILDREN THIS MAY BE
THEIR ONLY MEAL OF THE DAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS I'M RUNNING THIS YEAR
THAN I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE RAFFI PROGRAM AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
PROSECUTOR SACRAMENTO CALCRAFT
AWARDS. FUNDING FUNDING WILL
GREATLYHELP THE STUDENTS BOTH
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND CURRENT
COST USER EXPERIENCE INCREASES
OF HOMELESSNESS HOUSING
INSTABILITY FOOD INSECURITY AND
GENERAL FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES
BECAUSE THEY'LL CALL THE
NINETEEN THESE ISSUES AND
INTENSIFIED AND INCREASED. AS A
STUDENT AND AN EMPLOYEE I CAN
CONFIRM THAT SAYS THAT THESE
EXTRA FUNDS WOULD BE OF GREAT
HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
PINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DESIGNED BY
HERBERT I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS.
MY MY RECOMMENDATION FOR A
PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING BUT IT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WITH A
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT WARD I
HAVE WORKED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE PROGRAM SERVING
STUDENTS AFFECTED BY THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM FOR THE PAST FOUR
YEARS IN THAT TIME EUROPEAN
STUDENTS I'VE WITNESSED
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES THESE
STUDENTS FACE ALMOST DIDN'T OUR
LOW INCOME THEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
UNIQUE BARRIERS I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW MORE JUST ONE MORE REASON
FOSTER CARE MOVES TOWARDS AT
LEAST ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR BY
THE TIME THE AGE OF THE SYSTEM
OVER A THIRD WILL BE
EXPERIENCED FIVE OR MORE SCHOOL
MAN. AFTER MAY A DILUTES SIX
MONTHS OF I CAN ECONOMIC. PER
MOVE WHICH PUTS MOST DIDN'T
YEARS BEHIND THEIR- IN ADDITION
DISPLACING CARE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY OVER
REPRESENTED BY STUDENTS OF
COLOR MAKING THIS AN
INTERSECTIONAL EQUITY ISSUE.
THIS SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO HELP
STUDENTS TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
JANET BUT IT MALINA I AM A
COUNSELOR AND COORDINATOR FOR
THE SAKE THREE BILLIONS IN
EDUCATION COLLEGE PROGRAM AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS
USED WITH SUPPLEMENTAL PROGRAM
ALIVE. I WORK CLOSELY WITH
CURRENT AND FORMER BALK AT YOU
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE ANY SCHOLARS BASED
MULTIPLE CHALLENGES TOUCH ARE.
BLOCK OF FAMILY SUPPORT THE
WORK MULTIPLE JOBS WITH THE NFL
AND DEAL WITH THE VARIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES DUE TO THE
TRAUMA THEY FACE ARE THE RESULT
OF FOSTER. CARE EXPERIENCE.
CALLER STRUGGLE MORE ROLE. AND
IDENTITY SUCH BEEN AND OFF OF
IT AND PARENTS. ANY SACRIFICE
SO MUCH OF THEMSELVES TO BE
CRITICS LEADING CAUSE. ONE WILL
HELP WITH THEIR BASIC NEEDS. N.
MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT BUT TO BE
TO GROW AND GET THEIR DEGREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NAY CALL. NINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA LOPEZ I'M CALLING
FROM MOUNTING REYES UNIVERSITY
IN LOS ANGELES AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING
INCLUDING THE GOVERNMENT'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WITH SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT
AWARDS BUT YOU YOU MAY NOT HAVE
THE SUPPORT FOR MCCARTY AND-
LEVINE. CARE OR FINANCE AND
LIFE THEN DURING THEIR YOUNG.
YEARS THEY MAY HAVE TO WORK
MULTIPLE JOBS TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES THE STATE HOME THAT
IS CONDUCIVE TO LEARNING AND
CURRENTLY. REMOTE LEARNING.
THIS GRANT WILL PREDICT REDUCE
FOOD INSECURITY AND HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT WHERE THEY WOULD
GET FROM FOOD FROM. TODAY I
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO. OF THE DEADLY
IMPACT ACADEMIC SUCCESS BY
HAVING FUNDS TO PURCHASE.
ESSENTIAL THINGS FOR DAY TO DAY
AND MATERIALS FOR CLASSES SUCH
AS BOOKS. LAPTOPS. AND
NOTEBOOKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MARK NEXT CALL. ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK TWENTY FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD FOR. HELLO MY NAME IS
MARANDA NINETY OUT MOST ALL
COLLEGE I AM A FORMER FOSTER
CHILD AND WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
BUT FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH GRANT
AWARD. I HAVE BEEN IN AND OUT
OF BOX CARE ARE MY CHAU. AND
YOUR AGE THIRTEEN BUT I WAS
PLEASED IN KINSHIP CARE. AND
JUDGING EIGHTEEN I LIKE
CHILDREN BEEN EXPOSED TO AND
UNSTABLE WIFI. GROWING UP.
UNFORTUNATELY AND I'M I DON'T
FOLLOW FOR THE CAN WRAP. THAT
CALTRAIN IT WOULD BE AN ACTIVE
PRAYER I HAD THE BILL THE TO
BECAUSE MY GOAL AND- PLACE ON
FOSTER CHILDREN. BUT I DON'T.
THE GUY I THINK I THINK MY.
THIS BUDGET RANGE WHAT REDUCE
OFF ME OTHER OUR STRUCTURES
CRIME GIVE THE ODDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MODERATOR CALL. WINDS SAID
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SHANTA T. AND I AM TO- I
STILL ACCOUNT FAMILY I AM ALSO
FORMER. AND I ALSO MY ENTRY. AT
HAVE YOU KNOW WITH OUR AUSTRIAN-
I'D LIKE EXPRESS FOR THE FUNDS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR BUT
PROPOSED TO GROW KERR INCOME
ACOSTA. WITH A BILL MEANT COG
AWARD. LIKE A LOT OF MY. MY
STUDENTS I WORK WITH.
EXPERIENCE TRY AND- I'LL HAVE
TO OVER TO. TOTALLY MENTAL
HEALTH. MENTAL DISABILITIES-
I'M ACTUALLY- COMPLETING MY
MSW- AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ACTIVELY- ELIMINATE THESE
BARRIERS THAT WE HAVE TO FACE
AND OVERCOME- I MOVED A LOT IN
FOSTER CARE- WHICH ALSO
CONTRIBUTE TO MY DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS HAVING TO LOOK SCHOOLS-
I ALSO DON'T HAVE FAMILY
SUPPORT- IT CURRENTLY EVEN
COMPLETING MY GRADUATE SCHOOL-
I DIDN'T HAVE PEOPLE HOUSING
AND- KNOWING THAT THIS THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE.
DEFINITELY HELPED ME. NOT HAVE
TO OVERCOME THOSE BARRIERS- I
WOULD JUST LIKE FUTURE STUDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT HAVE TO WORK
HARDER. AND BE ABLE TO JUST
HAVE THE SUPPORT AND IT EASIER
ON THEM AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORK HARDER THAN SOMEBODY THAT
WASN'T A FARMER. THANK YOUNG
COMPANY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS A CIRCLE I LIVE IN
DISTRICT NINE I MIDDLE I'M NOT
OF THE RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM AT CAL STATE EAST BAY
THAT THEIR CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH I SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE FOSTER YOUTH
WITH SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
NON ACADEMIC NEEDS THE LAST
THING THAT BOB DYLAN MY COLLEGE
SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IS
MEETING THEIR BASIC NEEDS. I
KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE OF THE
UNDERGRAD I NEEDED DENTAL WORK
THAT I COULD NOT AFFORD BECAUSE
OF THE EMERGENCY FUNDING MADE
POSSIBLE BY DONATIONS TO THE
RED GONZALEZ TRIGRAM I WAS ABLE
TO PAYFOR MUCH NEEDED DENTAL
WORK I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO STAY IN SCHOOL WITHOUT THIS
NON ACADEMIC SUPPORT AS A
VOLUNTEER AND THAT MANY FOSTER
YOUTH IN COLLEGE WHO ARE FACING
HOMELESSNESS ARE BEING UNABLE
TO PAY THEIR BILLS. WELL THE GP
GRANT HAS INCREASED THE NUMBER
OF ATTENDING COLLEGE- OR STILL
STRUGGLING TO STAY IN SCHOOL
DUE TO FINANCIAL STRESS THE
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR NON
ACADEMIC NEEDS TO ELIGIBLE
FOSTER YOUTH WILL HELP INCREASE
GRADUATION RATES SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN THINK THE. AT THE
CREEK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A MODERATOR NECK CALL.
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE CALL. HI
AT NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WICKS
IS AND I'M ALSO FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND- I'M NOT DAY THAT.
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS USED
WITH THAT- CAL GRANT WORK.
UNDERSTANDING THAT. HALF OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE GROW FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND IN 324% OF OUR AYE
SHE'S ACTUALLY GRADUATE FROM
YEAR COLLEGE YOU. CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S A FEAT IN
ITSELF TO GET THE COLLEGE PARK
WALL STREET. ONE STARTING THE
JOURNEY IS WHERE THEY BEAT THE
MOST. MORE SO THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BEING A BIG PART OF
THAT. ISSUE HAVE ONLY BEEN IN.
DURING THE COPA NINETY AND THAT.
IT'S TIME TO ADDRESS THE CORE
SURE EQUITY IN EXCESS HIGHER.
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT A LOT OF
THESE. ARE DUE TO. PHYSICAL
RESTRICTIONS THAT THEY THINK. I
HOPE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ON MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE
THIRTY THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JORDAN
VOTE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE AND
POLICY MANAGER OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION WE'RE A
NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION BUT FOSTER CARE
EXPERIENCE WORK POWER TO
TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM THAT
LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND PRACTICE
CHANGE AND CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SUPPLEMENT
AWARDS FOR FOX USED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE SUPPLEMENT TO THE CAL GRANT
AWARD. BY THE FORMER BOSS
YOU'VE MARKED UP FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND A STUDENT
FROM CAPITALIST OR FULLER CAN
GUARDIANS COLLEGE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN ACCESS TO RESOURCES- TO
RESOURCE THAT THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT HELP ME BATTLE
STABILITY IN A SENSE OF
BELONGING MY. FAMILY AND ME.
CALIFORNIANS CONNECTION
DEDICATED TO ABBOTT. FOR A
STATE WILL SUPPORT EVERY USED
AND PACKED BY CALIFORNIANS
WHILE SYSTEM. AND I WOULD
GREATLY. THE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON EXPANDING CAL GRANT
AWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
FIND SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DONNIE LAWRENCE
AND THE STUDENT SUPPORT
COORDINATOR FOR THE RECYCLAGE
NEXTSTEP PROGRAM I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT FORMER BOSTON
WITH APPLE MENTAL HEALTH GRANT
AWARD MY LITTLE HAS AFFORDED ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
DIRECTLY FROM OUR CURRENT
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH REGARDING
THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE. MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS FACE CHALLENGES
IN OBTAINING A POINT EMPLOYMENT
AND COME STRUGGLE JUGGLING WORK
IN SCHOOL WHICH IS COMPOUNDED
BY THE SITUATE IT COMPOUND THE
SITUATION- BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
DO NOT HAVE OR NETWORK SUCH AS
FAMILY SUPPORT WHICH COULD HAVE
OTHERWISE. PROVIDES CRITICAL
SUPPORT TO THEM. A STUDENT OF
DRUG THAT HAS INSTEAD. WE
RESULTED IN HER. COUCH AT
LIVING THEIR CAR. OUR CURRENT
COMMENT FOSTER YOU STUDENT
HEAVILY RELY ON FINANCIALLY TO
MEET BASIC NEEDS INCLUDING
HOUSING COSTS AND UTILITIES.
I'M SURE THAT WITHOUT ADEQUATE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THEY CANNOT
CONTINUE PURSUING THEIR
EDUCATION WHICH CAN HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THEIR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE PROPOSAL
IS GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS RAM A FRENCHMAN MOUNT
ST MARY'S UNIVERSITY I AM A
CRANE FOSTER AND I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS. THE QUESTION OF
PROPOSING OF ON THE IT WOULD
HAVE NEED TO. ADULT THE COURT
CHIU THING COOL WHILE. THANK HI
SHOULD GET FROM TO SCHOOL OTHER
ERRANDS THAN MOST COULD GET
THROUGH AND IT WOULD HAVE ME
BECAUSE I JUST. THREE JOBS.
TRANSPORTATION AND MY LONG IN
MY LIFE CALDERON SAYS OF THEIR
BEING A NEEDS ON A THE LOCAL.
ALL THREE FOUR THAT'S NOT. FIND
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE ENGLISH NINE. YOU
AND I AM A BARKBOX I'M RIGHT BY
THE PORT BUT THE BANK AND.
THEY
ARE DOING IT OUT OF STATE AND
ARE RELYING ON YOU FOR THEM
BILITY. MARK HI EDUCATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. ONE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KEVIN ON THE LINE AND I
AM A FORMER PROSECUTOR WHO
CURRENTLY WORKS FOR COMMITTEE
GOT INTO COLLEGE I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE TO
THE GRUB BUDGET COUPLE TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL U. WHAT IS THE
COME AWARD. HAVING PARTICULARLY
A COPYING DOCTOR K. MY BELIEVE
THERE COULD A GREAT TO VEHICLE
HAD TRAUMA YOU MOVING AROUND
WHY IN THE CARE FROM. I
PERSONALLY HAVE WITH MANY TALK
COOLEY HOMELESSNESS AND HAVE
LITTLE TO REPORT FROM THERE
FAMILY. I ALSO- I PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED OTHERS MY CELL WHO
HONEST USED TO DRAW WITH FOOD
INSECURITY FROM THAT THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL HELP WITH
IT IS THAT THEY NEED TO KERR
ANY EXTREME THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
FIND SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SIGN AN
I'M WHICH COLLEGE IN HAYWARD
AND THE CORNERING CAL FOR THE
GARDEN SCHOLARS. I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE FIND
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE CURRENT
INCOME BOSS AT THE TOP OKAY
GRANT WORK THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
US TO SAVE NET THAT MAY DO NOT
HAVE TO THEIR IN WITH BOX CARE
SYSTEM IS TOO OFTEN THE I WORK
WITH THAT LACK FAMILY SUPPORT
FREQUENT SCHOOL MOVES HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS.
IT IS ARE HAVING TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN ATTENDING CLASS OR TAKE
ANY ADDITIONAL WORK SHIP SO
THEY CAN HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR FOOD. OR INTO A RIGHT TO
COVER THE TRANSPORTATION TO AND
FROM SCHOOL OR WORK. LET'S
SHARE THE RESPONSIBILITY.
INCREASE A SUPPLEMENTAL CAL
GRANT AND SUPPORT STUDENTS THAT
WERE IMPACTED BY THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. LET'S ELIMINATE
SOME OF THESE BARRIERS SO THEY
CAN JOIN THE PLAYING FIELD WITH
THEIR PEERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. FINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
INCREMENTAL THING POLICY
ADVISOR NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT THE- BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO CONFIRM THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETED
AXELLE OR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT APPLICATION FINANCIAL AID
IS CRITICAL FOR STUDENTS WITH
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE THE FACT THAT I'M MORE
LIKELY TO DIRECTLY ROLE IN
COLLEGE 90% STUDENT YOU DO
COMPLETE THE FACT THAT COMPARED
255% PEERS THAT DO NOT. AND NO
STUDENT SHOULD BE DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE YOUR
PROTECT YOUR EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY WERE NEVER MADE AWARE
OTHER FINANCIAL AID OPTIONS AND
THE PROPOSAL WILL INCREASE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ARE EXPECTED
THE IN DEPTH REPORT NEEDED TO
COMPLETE THE FORM WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CAL GRANT REFORM
WITH THE EQUITY FRAMEWORK THAT
THE FACT OUTLINED AND THE
CONTINUATION ELIMINATE.
ELIGIBILITY LET ME FOCUS ON
GETTING BASIC NEED ONLY GET AND
WHETHER AT. AND THE FOUR
CRITICAL THAN EVER GETTING THE-
CHALLENGES THE AND THEN. THANK
YOU. HANK YOU VERY. MONTEREY
MEXICO. FINE EIGHTY THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS THE CHEN
I AM THE EXECUTIVE OF THE
HEADQUARTERS OR COALITION THE
VOICE OF LABOR EMPLOYERS. IN
AGENCY THAT OF JEFF. WE WANT TO
ADDRESS THIS WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
INCREASE PARTLY O'CLOCK THE
FOCUS ON THE MENTORS HERE TODAY
IN STRONG. OF THE PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF. CAL
GRANT. WHICH WILL SUPPORT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WORKING
METER EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
GOALS. SO THEY CAN SECURE THE
GATE JOBS WITH THEM ACCORDINGLY
AND BENEFITS. I JUST THINK FOR
THE WORK WITH STRATEGIES ACT
WOULD DIE DEVELOP PHOTO
DISTRICT IN THE COUNTY PARK. TO
REMOVE OF BARRIERS BECAUSE BY
ELEGY BURKE. MUSICAL FROM.
ADULTS ADULTS TO UPSKILL SECURE
GET JOBS STRONG SUPPORT THE
CHANGES. EDGE HOW TO DRAW YOU
THE BRITISH FROM COOPER.
WITHOUT FOR FUNDING WE CANNOT
REALLY THIS TRUE REFORM WE
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT REALITY BUT
ALSO BELIEVE THAT NOT GET. YOU
CAN THE THAT WE URGE THIS BE
TO. WE ALSO A BILL PER FROM
ALREADY LIMITED AMOUNT TO KERR
STUDENTS ARE NOT FOR AFTER THE
REDUCE. AND WE WOULD LIKE FOR
THAT COUPLE TO INCLUDE. AWARD
INCREASES OVER TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH TROUBLE YOU GO QUITE A
BIT OVER MINUTES TO ANSWER I'M
TO THANK FOR YOUR- AND ASKED
THE MODERATOR TO MOVE. TO THE
NEXT CALL. FIND SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MANY
CHAIR IN MEMBER MY NAME IS YOU
KNOW YOU FIND THE BIG DIRECTOR
FOR THE COW YOUTH CONNECTION I
WANT TO- DARCY. IN IN IN THE
KERN. BUDGET ASK IN THAT JUST
WHEN YOU KNOW THAT YOU'VE
AROUND CALIFORNIA ARE- ARE VERY
MUCH IN NEED OF AN INCREASE TO
THE CAL GRANT WILL ARE
TEMPERAMENTAL CAL GRANT AWARD
AND AT THE FORMER POSSES
MYSELF- WERE VERY MUCH IN
STRONG SUPPORTER AND WE AND WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
INDIVIDUAL AND URGENT NEED A
YEAR THAT THEY COME OUT AND WE
KNOW THEY'RE REALLY EXACERBATED
DURING THAT TIME A KOBE THANK
YOU MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR MEXICO. ONE EIGHTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS DIRECTLY TO MONTROSE
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS FOR YOU NATALIE I'LL BE
HAPPY NINE OH EIGHT I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT IMPOSTER FONG
KERN FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WITH
DOUBLE DOUBLE MENTAL PROGRAM
AWARDS- WALL STREET ALREADY
FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES WITH
HAVING THE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO COMPLETE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
DURING A PANDEMIC- WE WILL BE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
OVERLOOKED POPULATION OF
STUDENTS BUT ALREADY FACE IS
BURIED TO BE CHANGED
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY CODE
NINETEEN HAVE BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC AND EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
FOR STUDENTS IN GENERAL AND THE
NEGATIVE. IMPACT AT SOME POINT
YOU GREATER PREPOSTEROUS. THE
NEW TO JUST SUPPORT EMPLOYEE.
HOUSING TO SECURE AND
TECHNOLOGY. NOW BECOME INCREASE
TO TAXES FOR STUDENTS WERE ONE
CAN FOSTER CARE. WHILE FROM
EDUCATE EQUITY STANDPOINT WE
MUST FOCUS ON HELPING THE
STUDENT ADVOCATE A PANDEMIC I
KNOW PROBABLY DEAL WITH
CONSIDER CHALLENGES WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SUPPORT- OUR
BASIC NEEDS. IN A COUPLE OF
CONSPIRATORS FOR THEM NOW AND
THE YEARS TO COME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANE SCHROEDER
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF FIRST
PLACE FOR YOU THE LARGEST
ORGANIZATION EXCLUSIVELY
SERVING YOUNG PEOPLE AS THEY
AGE OUT OF THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM I'D LIKE TO SIXTY
EXPRESS THEIR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE FUNDING INCLUDING IN
THE GOT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO PROVIDE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
COULD SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT
AWARD IN OUR ROLE SUPPORTING
YOU TO REACH INDEPENDENT AFTER
INVOLVEMENT IN FOSTER CARE WE
SEE FIRSTHAND THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES OF POPULATION FACES
AND ACCESSING POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION INCLUDING A LACK OF
FAMILY SUPPORT INFREQUENT
HOUSING INSTABILITY. WHILE THE
STATE MADE HUGE STRIDES IN
STRENGTHENING OUR EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
THESE YOUNG ADULTS THERE'S
STILL A MASSIVE GAP IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION PERSISTENCE
AND WE BELIEVE THAT BUDGET
PROPOSAL CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. A MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. PINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
AHEAD. HELLO I'M LYNN AREN'T
AND I'M FROM THE YELLOW COUNTY
FOSTER KINSHIP CARE EDUCATION
PROGRAM AND THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING TO PROVIDE CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT AWARDS.
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH HAVE HIGH
FINANCIAL NEED DUE TO A LACK OF
FAMILY SUPPORT AS WELL AS
EXTRAORDINARY BEARING YEARS DUE
TO PREVIOUS TRAUMA THIS GRANT
SUPPORTS THE VIEWS AND A MORE
EQUITABLE WAY AND SUPPORT THEM
IN THEIR NON ACADEMIC NEEDS SO
THEY CAN PROPERLY FOCUSED ON
THEIR EDUCATION AND BUILD A
BETTER FTURE FOR THEMSELVES.
AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CAR.
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO TRAILER TO MEMBERS MY
NAME IS VICTOR JIMENEZ IN THE
CHECK A COLLEGE I'M HERE TODAY
AS PART OF THE BIG FINANCIAL
AID COALITION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OUR
STUDENTS AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
A ROBUST AND MEANINGFUL CAL
GRANT WATER MITIGATION EFFORT.
THE DYNAMIC HAS MEANT THAT MANY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS EET BUT THE
FAILURE OF OUR FINANCIAL SYSTEM
TO COVER COLLEGE COSTS DID NOT
BEGIN WITH THE PANDEMIC IT WAS
ONLY BROTHER. BY IT WE NEED OUR
STATE CONVENTION OUR STUDENTS
BECAUSE WE ARE THE ONES WHO
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA'S ENGINE AND
ITS ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM THIS
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND AND WE
CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT A
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT IN OUR
STATE CON. ACTUALLY THANK YOU
AND I HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU VERY. MODERATOR NECK
CALLER. BLIND TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DR CUPCAKES I'M CALLING FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE WHERE I SPOKE AT
PROTECTIVE TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
GUARDIAN COLLEGE PROGRAM THAT
THE COURT AFTER YOUR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS. I AM
CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
AUSTRIAN THE TECHNICAL CALTRANS
FOR DOCTOR YOU CAN NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN ON THE CHILDREN OF
OUR STATE WE CERTAINLY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION BUT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THEM I
PERSONALLY THINK THE WORLD OF
DIFFERENCE SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
HE COULD HAVE THE ABILITY
CREATE HEALTH CARE. PRICE
SIXTEEN IN COLLEGE DID NOT
MENTION THE DIFFERENCE A
COLLEGE DEGREE MAKE THE
LIABILITY AND PARTLY FOR THE
WELL BEING OF OUR COMMUNITY I
KNOW A LOT OF MENTION
COMPLEXITY BUT THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING MORE COMPLEX THAN
TRYING TO NAVIGATE COLLEGE AND
LIKE WITH AN EXTENSIVE HISTORY
OF CARE GIVING AN EDUCATIONAL
DESTRUCTION. AFTER THE PORT
FROM FAMILY OR FUNNY I'M ALL
FOR STREAMLINING THE PROCESS
BUT IS YOUR TURN SUPPORT FOR
THE DIRE NEED TO BE NOW I HOPE
WE WON'T LET COMPLEXITY STAND
IN OUR WAY TO DO CAR NAVIGATING
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES AND
SURELY WE CAN DO THE SAME THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT QUOTE. TWENTY
NINE. YOUR LINE IS A- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JOSH REAGAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMP FOR
COLLEGE. WE ARE TO GOV BUDGET
FOR THE CREDIT INVEST IN A BIRD
AID INCREASE COMPARED TO CAL
AWARD AND WE WERE TO LET TO
BUILD ON BUY AND EQUITY IS
CENTER OF OUR- AID. IMPALA THIS
ONLY THE FOUNDATION COULD
BECOME DOWN AHEAD DIFFICULTY WE
ARE STILL TO SUPPORT A COUPLE
IN PARKING CAL GRANT AWARDS SH
THE GOVERNOR BUDGET ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE HELLO HAS BEEN
CRITICAL ABOUT 10% IN 45% IN
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN TOP ABOUT
IN CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION COMPLETION RATES
RESPECTIVELY. HOW TO
PORTABILITY IS A SINGLE BARRIER
FACING INCOME STUDENT. AT THE
COURSE WORK AND FIRST ABOUT
SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
CREDENTIAL A CHALLENGE WHICH
CAN BE ADDRESSED IN PART BY
INTENTIONALLY INCREASING
STUDENT UTILIZATION OF
AVAILABLE FEDERAL AID. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO MANDATE
PASSPORT CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION FOR HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. BY NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THERE GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SHERRY RODRIGUEZ AND
I'M WITH LOS ANGELES VALLEY
COLLEGE AND THE DEAN OF SPECIAL
PROGRAMS AND I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE- GUARDIAN SCHOLARS NEXT
UP PROGRAM THAT SERVES FOSTER
YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN THE
STUDENTS AND MY COLLEAGUES IN
EXPRESSING MY SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FOSTER
YOUTH WITH SUPPLEMENTAL CAL
GRANT AWARDS- AND YOU KNOW HERE
IN CALIFORNIA OUR BASIC NEEDS
ARE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE AND SO
I FEEL THAT IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO YOU TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL CAL GRANT FUNDING TO
MEET THESE BASIC MEANS
ESPECIALLY HERE IN LOS ANGELES.
WE HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE
LIVING IN THERE ARE THESE WE
HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE LIVING
IN SHELTERS AND BY BELIEVE THIS
FUNDING WOULD GO A LONG WAY IN
HELPING THEM MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR MEXICO. FINALLY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVERYONE MY
NAME IS CANDACE PARKER LOPEZ I
AM PARTIALLY STUDENT AT
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDING IN THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR. BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO THE RIGHT CURRENT
AND FORMER BOSS YOU TO A
TROUBLE UNTIL CALLED AWARD. THE
WASHINGTON STUDENT ANASTASIA.
ABILITY UNIQUE. DRAMATIC NOT.
LIKE MY FORCING I CALL OKAY
SUPPORT AND PLEASE TELL INCLUDE
SECURITY. THERE HAVE BEEN WITH
A BY TO FROM GRANT. HELP HELP
STABILIZE MY LIVING SITUATION
WHICH ALLOW ME TO FOCUS ON MY
CHANGE OF RECEIVING A POSTCARD.
AND. AGAIN AS A FOR WASHU
STUDENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR FUNDING IN
THE- BY PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
INCOME OF WASHING IT WITH SOAP.
CAL GRANT WILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. MODERATOR
COMMON. NINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS PAUL BERRY I CURRENTLY
ATTENDS ABOUT COLLEGE AND I'M A
GUARDIAN SCHOLARS IN THE SYSTEM
AND FORMER CROSS YOU KNOW LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
GROW- CURRENT AND FORMER YOU
WILL SUPPLEMENT CAL A WAR. THE
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT STUDENTS
WHO MAY BE HOME CAN FOR DAILY
NEED AND HOW MAY BE ON THE-
WERE LOWER HOURS A WEEK MY
WHOLE COLLEGE CAREER IN THIS
BUDGET WILL NOT ONLY HELP
FOSTER YOU WILL FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES BUT WHILE THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. WILL FOSTER
WILL ALSO RAISE THE GRADUATION
RATE WHICH WILL LEAD TO
IMPROVED HEALTH LOWER
UNEMPLOYMENT MORE EDUCATED
CHILDREN AND HIGHER. LEVELS OF
HAPPINESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- AMADA NICK
CALL. FINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN MANY MY
NAME IS ARIEL AND I'M A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH I'M CURRENTLY I'M
ATTENDING CONGRESS TOOK OF
STATE UNIVERSITY I LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR
BUDGET. TO PROVIDE AND FORMER
YOU COULD SOMEONE SO HOW GRANT.
I'M FARMERS BLACKS THERE'S A-
I'M TAKING I HAVE PARENTS THAT
THEY WROTE THAT THEY CAN RELY
ON FOR COLLEGE AND THEY DO NOT
A STATE NET. I POSH YOUTH
LEAGUE OUT. BY TRYING TO KILL
THE TRI THERE. WELL BOUNCE OUT
LIFE. SUCH AS. CALLING CHILDREN
EVEN BALLOT- WHILE TRYING TO
WORK THIS FOR COULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE OF A FORMER YOUTH.
COLLEGE AND BUILD A BETTER
FUTURE PROGRAMS- NEED SCORER
WITH THE DRUG AND MOST LIKELY
STUDENT LOAN DEBT THEY'LL BE ON.
TO WORK IT BACK DURING THE I'M
PROUD. I I'M TIME AND I'M I CAN
AND FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE. I
HOPE THIS. THANK YOU AT THE
FUNDING IS CRITICAL FOR
FOSTERING. ALSO CARRILLO FOR TO
BREAK THE BANK OF THE OF POWER
THAT HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
YOU GO A BIT OVER A MINUTE TO
ARE WE PER SHARE YOUR COM
MONDAY NECK CALL. LINE NINETY
THREE YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NUMBER
SECOND HE'LL HEAR THE NEXT KEEP
IT PROGRAM THAT AIRS FOSTER. IT
LOOKS THE I WOULD LIKE EXPRESS
MY THOUGHTS FOR THE FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE CALL BY COOK.
TO PROVIDE CURRENT FORMER
FOSTER WITH THE MOMENTUM
GROUNDWORK FOR ARE YOU THANK
CHALLENGE IN THEIR IN. HELPING
THINK YOU'RE AND LA OF FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THEREFORE HAVING
ACTED ADDITIONAL WILL. BENEFIT
FROM YOUTH STUDENT AND HOW THEM
COMPLETE THEIR LOOKING AND
CAREER THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOUR COM MODERATOR CALL.
LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOR US. YES HELLO THANK YOU SO
MUCH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MY
NAME IS AND HAWTHORNE DIRECTOR
KIDS CITY COLLEGE ACCESS AND
pANGELES. ONE OF OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES OUTSIDE OF LONDON
ASKING EACH READ THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENT TODAY SHE'S A DREAMER
AND A HISTORY MAJOR AT. I'M
HONORED TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE COMPLETION OF FAST
URGING ACT APPLICATIONS BY
EVERY STUDENT. AS AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT MY MAIN
CONCERN WHEN APPLYING TO
COLLEGE WAS AFFORDABILITY
COMPLETING THE DREAM ACT EVERY
YEAR HAS ALLOWED ME TO ATTEND
U. S. B. FOR FOUR YEARS THAT
FOR ME. AND NOT EVERY STUDENT
HAS THE ABILITY OUR PRIVILEGE
TO JOIN ORGANIZATIONS THAT
GUIDE GUIDE THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF APPLYING FOR
FINANCIAL AID. ATTENDING
COLLEGE IS A LIFE CHANGING
MOMENT ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THEY SHOULD NOT
BE PUNISHED BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF INFORMATION AND THE
COMPLICATED NATURE OF THE
APPLICATION. BY ALLOCATING
FUNDS TO ENSURE ALL STUDENTS
COMPLETE THE FASTER DREAM ACT
WE WOULD BE CARING FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T KNOW THESE OPTIONS
EXIST. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. FINE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
BRITNEY AMERICANS LOOK MENTAL
FOR THE MY TO LAST WEEK CALLED
THAT YOU PROBABLY CALL- I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY FOR THE
FUNDING INCREASE IN THE GOOD
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS G. WITH
THE OF NINETY CAL GRANT AWARD A
FEW CHALLENGES THE FONG YOU
THEY ARE HOW. THE AND HOME.
GOOD JOB LOSS PERSONAL ISSUES
TO PREVIOUS I BORROWED BY COULD
BECAUSE FROM THE I DON'T CARE
GIVERS. PHONE. BLIND EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KIRTI ACOSTA I AM ATTENDING
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICO AND I AM A FORMER BOARD
AT COURT UNLIKE THE PARTICIPANT
FONG- THE FUNDING INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PEOPLE THAT
PROVIDE KERN FROM THE FACTORY
WITH A METAL CAL GRANT AWARD IN
MY PERSONAL CASE MY MOTHER
PASSED AWAY WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN
I AM NOT YOU A FULL TIME
STUDENT CAREGIVER FOR MY UNCLE
IS THE BIG ONE AND CURRENTLY.
WORKING ACTOR TO OVER COME
OBSTACLES I COULD NOT WORK I
THANK. MICHAEL IS THAT OF US
ALL. EIGHT TRAUMA OF BEING
AGENTS UP BY I NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO THEIR BE THERAPEUTIC OF MY
PRIOR- FOR HOUSING AND FOOD IS
BEEN ABOUT THREE BUT IT HAD
PAID THE LECTURE. I'VE BEEN ON
THE VERGE OF DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL COMPLETELY THE
TEMPERATURE IN A FINAL THE LAW.
THANK THE HARD THE MATTERI
BURKE THE JOB THAT THE FOR AND.
AFTER TAKING SOME OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING EXPERIENCES THAT
ARE DEVELOPING YOUNG AGES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ASIAN MAKE THEM LAUGH I'M A
FORMER AUSTRALIAN AND ADVOCATE
HI JOHN THAT FOR YOU. AND THE
STUDENTS SACRAMENTO- LIKE
PICTURES FOR THE INCLUDED IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PRINT KERN INCOME FOSTER. MOST
OF THEM SO CAL GRANT AWARDS
MANY FRUSTRATING LACRIM ACROSS
FROM. UNSTABLE HOW AN EXTRA
HOMELESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS OF
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. LINE ONE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ERIC ROMERO
AND ON BEHALF OF THESE OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WE
WILL LIKE TO HELP A DEFINING
AID FOR YOU WE SUPPORT THE OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL REQUIREMENTS THE
CALIBER PROGRAMS. BUT SHORT OF
THE LOWER TAKING THAT THIS YEAR
WE ASK THAT THE LEAD ALLOWED
LAST YEAR'S GROW CLASS AS WELL
AS THIS YEAR'S CLASS ADDITIONAL
TIME TO CALL THE ENTIRE CAL.
BEFORE THE THRONE AND TO THE
CAL GRANT. NO THERE'S AN
INCREASE IN THE OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO ARE FILING FASTER
OKAY DREAM UP WHICH AND MANY OF
THOSE EARLY. AND WHEN THEY GO
BACK IT GONNA BECOME A MAJOR IS
WHEN THEY TO THAT THEY HAVE NO
AID AVAILABLE TO THEM IF TIME
HAS RUN OUT FOR CAL INTEL. WE
SUPPORT THE RECALL. THE HIGH
SCHOOLS- OUT OF. KEY AS PART OF
THE MACHINE YEAR IN SCHOOL
DOING PROVIDES. I WORK WITH TAX
DOLLARS HE FOSTER SUPPORT
PROGRAM SHE DOES STATE AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ONE OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO WANTED TO BE HERE
TODAY THE COULD NOT ATTEND. MY
NAME IS CAROLYN I AM A SENIOR
SHE DOES STATE AND I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FOSTER
YOUTH THE SUPPLEMENTAL CAL
GRANT AWARD. CURRENTLY I AM
THINKING ABOUT GETTING A SECOND
JOB TO PAY MY BILLS BECAUSE THE
EIGHT EIGHT THAT IS NOT ENOUGH
TO MEET MY BASIC NEEDS AND I'M
SURE THERE ARE OTHER STUDENTS
IN MY SITUATION. AS WELL. WHEN
WE WENT ONLINE LAST SPRING I
HAD TO BUY A NEW COMPUTER SINCE
THIS HAS BECOME A NECESSITY FOR
VIRTUAL LEARNING. GRANT
INCREASEWOULD BE HELPFUL TO
PAY FOR NECESSITIES LIKE ONLINE
LEARNING AND KEEP STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF FROM HAVING TO WORK TWO
JOBS WHILE STILL FOCUSING ON
SCHOOL. BUT DOCTOR YOU GO TO
COLLEGE THERE ON THEIR OWN THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE WE
DEPEND ON THE SUPPORT PROGRAMS
AND FINANCIALLY TO GET THROUGH
SCHOOL. THIS GRANT WILL BE
HELPING A LOT OF STUDENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE ONE
ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JACOB
VIGIL- MY GRADUATE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
CALMER YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE KERN FORMER BOSS YOU'RE
A SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT AWARD.
BOB PURSUING MY UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE THE CALDERON AWARD
HELPED ME GREATLY WHAT
NONTRADITIONAL- LIVING COSTS.
AS A FULL TIME STUDENT- VERY
HARD FOR ME TO FIND- FLEXIBLE
PART TIME JOB. TO HELP SUPPORT
MY INCOME. CALDERON AWARD HELP
ME KEEP A ROOF OVER MY HEAD.
CHECK OUT PAY FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD IN MY
HOME SADLY IT WAS NEVER ENOUGH
BUT I FOUND WAYS TO MAKE IT
WORK DESPITE THE JOHN. THE
CRASH OF ATTENDING COLLEGE AS A
FIRST GENERATION STUDENT.
STRATHCONA FORWARD TO THE STATE
CAN ALSO HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
IF THEY WILL HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO PAY RENT. ARE YOU DECENT NOW.
CONSIDERATION IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE
ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS TIFFANY AND NOT
MECHANIC COMPLICATES MANAGER
FOR THE GUARDIAN SCHOLARS
PROGRAM AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY. I AM SURE AS THE
PRESIDENT YOU'RE A CURRENT OR
FORMER LAST YEAR AND I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THE TEMPERAMENTAL
CAL GRANT AWARD. A NEW STAFF
MEMBER ON CAMPUS NOW DURING
REMOTE LEARNING I'VE HEARD AND
SEEN THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR FOSTER YOUTH TO
SUPPORT THEIR PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. ANY FUNDING SOURCES
THAT CURRENTLY SUPPORT COSTS
YOU HAVE MANY RESTRICTIONS ON
HOW THEY CAN BE USED.
INTERSECTION COMMITTEE
CHALLENGING AND FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTING OTHER AREAS OF THEIR
LIVES ASIDE FROM TUITION THAT
ARE NECESSARY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN COLLEGE. MUST UNDERSTAND
THAT STUDENTS NEED TO HAVE FOOD
STABLE HOUSING CHILD CARE AND
TECHNOLOGY TO RECEIVE THEIR
DEGREE OUR STUDENTS HEAVILY
OFTEN SOLELY RELIANT FINANCIAL
AID TO CONTINUE WITH CALLS SUCH
AS CHILD CARE. LAUNDRY CLOSER
TIES TRANSPORTATION EVERYTHING
THAT IS NEEDED TO SUCCEED THE
CIVIC LEE ATTENDING SCHOOL IN
THE BAY AREA WHERE COST OF
LIVING. LIVING IS DRASTICALLY
HIGH. A COLLEGE STUDENT-
DEDICATED AMBITIOUS THANK. FOR
TO SUCCEED. THIS FUNDING WITH
THE PART THAT FORMER EMPLOYEES-
BITTER ONE. THANK YOU FOR
COMMON- MODEL NECK CALLER. LINE
ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHARLIE OR THE
NUMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JACKIE TOOK A LONG AND
I'M WITH THE AND CHAPAR
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN- I WANT TO
CALL AND EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WITH A BONTA
CALIBAN AWARD THE STATE. AND
THE ROLE OF PARENT HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE PROVIDED ALL THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES. TO SUCCEED IN THEIR
COLLEGE AND CAREER GOALS AS ANY
PARENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CALL MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. LINE ONE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA COREY AND I AM A
WOMAN WELL SHE ADDS I ATTEND
COLLEGE AT BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT INCOME ABORTION.
BUT SACRAMENTO CALCLOUD WARD. I
ABOUT I WENT TO COLLEGE FIVE
YEARS COLLEGE I AM ALSO A
PARENT AS WELL. GOING TO
COLLEGE IN. IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE I DIDN'T HAVE
MY FAMILY I DIDN'T HAVE MY
FAMILY SUPPORT- WHAT SO EVER
UNLIKE OTHER AND OTHER USE THAT
AREN'T IN QUESTION HERE AND
ALSO I WILL COME WITH YOU ON MY
FIRST YEAR IN COLLEGE SO THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD BE A
GREAT IDEA TO HELP THOSE. WHO
SUFFER FROM HOUSING INSTABILITY
BUT ALSO FOR THE YOUTH THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED THANK
YOU AND HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MODERATOR. DOES
THAT EXHAUST OR Q. YES MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUEUED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WE REALLY APPRECIATED
WE- BY MY COUNT HAD. BETWEEN
INCLUDING THE TWO FALSE STARTS
WIT FIFTY FOUR PEOPLE SO THANK
YOU FOR- ASSISTING THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT- I WOULD
THANK EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY AND IF
YOU'RE UNABLE TO TESTIFY OR
YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE FEW. THAT
JUST COULDN'T GET THERE IN THE
TIME ALLOTTED A PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEWS OF SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE BECAUSE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WICKED GOES
INTO THE OFFICIAL RECORD AND
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION. THANKS TO
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION IN THIS LONG
HEARING WE'VE COMPLETED THE
AGENDA AND THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE.
ONE IS ADJOURNED.